OKAY WE WILL WAIT TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM BUT ONE GARDEN GET
STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
THAT IS. THE CORRECT ALL RIGHT
AND SO- WITH THAT. WHEN THE
ADDRESS SOME LOGISTICS AND SOME
PROTOCOLS- SO DUE TO THE
CONTINUING COVER NINETEEN
CRISIS- WE CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE AND
THIS- THIS COMMITTEE ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
YOU KNOW FOR THOSE HERE IN
ATTENDANCE TODAY. BOTH A
HEARING PARTICIPANTS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE
KNOW THAT THROUGHOUT THIS
HEARING FACE COVERINGS ARE
REQUIRED. TO BE WORN AT ALL
TIMES AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE IT
IS EXPECTED TO BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A FACE COVERING
ONE SHALL BE PROVIDED TO YOU. I
DO THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS WE UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE LIMITED SEATING AVAILABLE
IN THIS HEARING ROOM AND WE
WILL BE CAREFULLY MODERATE
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT THE
HEARING. THERE ARE ELEVEN BILLS
ON OUR AGENDA IS TO BE-
CONSIDERED BY OUR COMMITTEE-
THREE WHICH HAVE BEEN PROPOSED
AS CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS- AND
FOR EACH ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
THERE WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT COMMENTS.
MAY BE MADE IN PERSON IN THIS
ROOM FROM A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION OR BY PHONE NOW THE
REMOTE ESTIMONY STATIONS ARE
LOCATED JUST OUTSIDE OF THIS
FACILITY IT IS BUILDING.
LOCATED ON THE NORTH SIDE OF
THE CAPITOL THE STATIONS ARE-
AVE. FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES OR
FOR ALL OR AS WELL FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THE PHONE NUMBER TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS DURING OUR
HEARING TODAY WILL BE SHOWN OR
PROVIDED TO VIEWERS ON SCREEN.
AS THIS- HEARING MOVES FORWARD.
THEN THE PHONE NUMBERS ALSO
POSTED ON OUR SIMPLY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND FOR THOSE WHO WILL
BE. PROVIDING COMMENTS TODAY.
WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR NAME AND IF APPLICABLE THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT. AND
IF YOU SUPPORTER OPPOSE THE
BILL BEING. CONSIDERED NOW ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IS WELCOME
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
OUR COMMITTEE THROUGH EMAIL.
THE EMAIL ADDRESSES A. G. R. I.
EIGHT DOT. COMMITTEE AT ASM DOT
CA DOT GOP YOU CAN ALSO BE
FOUND ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE-
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL
OF. OF HUMANISM AS MUCH FROM
THE PUBLIC WITHIN THE LIMITS OF
OUR TIME. WE WILL NOT. IT- WE
WILL NOT. PERMIT. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY SO PLEASE
BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY BE SUBJECT- TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY- AND SO- WITH THAT.
WHEN A WELCOME MEMBERS OF THE
OF. THE ASSEMBLY TO THIS
COMMITTEE LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH EACH. OF THE U. THIS
SESSION AND WE WILL CERTAINLY
HAVE SOME INTERESTING
LEGISLATION PROPOSAL SOME OF US
IN PROPOSED BILLS THAT WILL BE
BEFORE US AND I EXPECT. SOME-
SOME GOOD DID. SOME
DISCUSSIONS- THROUGHOUT THIS
YEAR- ARE- HI COMMITTEE VICE
CHAIRS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
MISTER VICE CHAIR YOU'RE
WELCOME TO MAKE SOME BRIEF
OPENING COMMENTS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
LIKE TO WELCOME EVERYBODY IF
YOU. ARE EXPERIENCE- THE
CHAIRMAN SAID WE WILL
DEFINITELY BE DIVING INTO
SUMMER BUS AGRICULTURAL ISSUES.
THIS YEAR AS THINGS MOVE
FORWARD. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION HEALTHY DEBATE
AND MAKING SURE AGRICULTURE AND
OUR FOOD SUPPLY IN THE STATE-
REMAIN A KEY ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND SO-
WITH THAT- WE CAN WE CAN'T TAKE
ANY VOTES BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM YET- BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY CAN HEAR OUR
FIRST BILL RIGHT. AND SO WILL
TAKE UP THE COULD THINK UNDER
ONCE WE- A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. AND SO- THE- ALL
OF THE- BILLS ARE ON OUR AGENDA
WILL BE HEARD IN FILE ORDER.
WITH THE FIRST BEING FILE
NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO ZERO NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLUE MISCIBLE MARKHAM TO
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE. AND WE
ARE READY WHEN YOU ARE. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES IT'S GOOD
TO BE HERE AND I AM PLEASED TO
BE PRESENTING A. B. ONE ZERO
ZERO NINE WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
FARM TO SCHOOL FOOD HUB PROGRAM
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF FARM TO
FORK IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE. AND PROPOSES
FUNDING FOR A REGIONAL PILOT
PROGRAM TO ESTABLISH THREE FARM
TO SCHOOL FOOD HUBS IN NORTHERN.
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOOD JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE
LOCATED ON THE EASTERN SEABOARD
IN CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY HAS-
AROUND FIFTEEN WHICH OPERATE AT
DIFFERENT SCALES AND A MORE
CONCENTRATED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. FOOD HAVE OFFER A
REGIONALISED APPROACH TO FOOD
DISTRIBUTION THAT HAS PROVEN TO
BE A SUCCESSFUL MODEL FOR
PROMOTING DIRECT FARM AND RANCH
SALES TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
RESULTED IN THE
UNPREDICTABILITY AND LOSS OF
MARKETS WHICH HAS HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL SCALE
FARMERS. PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
ARE HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
FARMERS OF COLOR. FOOD SYSTEM
REFORM INCREASINGLY CALLS FOR
MORE REGIONALIZED FOOD SYSTEMS.
WHICH IN TURN PROVIDE GREATER
RESILIENCE IN TIMES OF NATURAL
OR PUBLIC HEALTH DISASTER.
DURING THE PANDEMIC THOSE AREAS
THAT HAD COMMUNITY FACING FOOD
HUBS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PIVOT
QUICKLY TOWARD REDIRECTING
THEIR SUPPLY CHANGE TO AREAS OF
NEED. AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF
THE SUCCESS OF THIS MODEL IS
THE COMMON MARKET. A NONPROFIT
FOOD HUB OPERATING IN
PHILADELPHIA NEW YORK GEORGIA
AND TEXAS WHICH PROVIDED
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL FARMERS AND
EMERGENCY FOOD RELIEF DURING
THE PANDEMIC. WELL CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE NATION IN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION WITH
THE FARM ECONOMY VALUED AT
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE LAG BEHIND IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF REGIONAL IS
FOOD SYSTEMS WHICH REQUIRE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT IN
AGGREGATION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
INCREASE PURCHASING OF LOCAL
CLIMATE FRIENDLY AND EQUITABLY
PRODUCED FOOD. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT A
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
INTERMEDIARY SUPPLY CHAIN
SUPPORT FOR SCHOOLS AND OTHER
LARGE SCALE INSTITUTIONS. LOOK
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL FOR FOOD
HUBS IS NECESSARY IN ORDER TO
BUILD BACK A BETTER FOOD SYSTEM
A KANEMI SUPPORT LOCAL FARMING
ECONOMIES ACCELERATE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCE AND
RE EMPLOY FOOD SYSTEM WORKERS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND OTHER
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN
ENDEAVORING TO LEVERAGE THEIR
SIGNIFICANT FOOD PURCHASING
BUDGETS TOWARD THESE POSITIVE
PUBLIC VALUES AND AB TEN OH
NINE PROVIDES THE CRITICAL
MISSING PIECE TO SUPPORT THEM
IN THE THOSE EFFORTS IN
ADDITION TO CREATING JOBS. AND
SPURRING LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AB TEN OH NINE
WILL ALSO SUPPORT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS THEY RECOVER
FROM THE DRASTIC ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE FARM TO SCHOOL
FOOD HUBS CREATED UNDER THIS
BILL WILL PRIORITIZE
AGGREGATION AND DISTRIBUTION
FROM SMALL TO MID SCALE FARMS
AND RANCHES THAT ARE
COOPERATIVELY OWNED OR OWNED BY
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
BEGINNING LIMITED RESOURCE
VETERANS MINORITY OR DISABLED
FARMERS AND RANCHERS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND OTHER PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. AB TEN OH NINE
WILL INCREASE PURCHASING OF
LOCAL CLIMATE FRIENDLY AND
EQUITABLY PRODUCED FOOD BUILD A
BETTER FOOD SYSTEM A KANEMI
SUPPORT LOCAL FARMING ECONOMIES
ACCELERATE CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCE. AN EMPLOYEE
FOOD SYSTEM WORKERS
ADDITIONALLY THESE FOOD HUBS
WILL SERVE AS A MODEL FOR THE
REST OF THE STATE TO FOLLOW AND
HOPEFULLY ADOPT I AM PLEASED TO
HAVE PAULA DANIELS CO FOUNDER
OF THE CENTER FOR GOOD FOOD
PURCHASING. AND SCOTT BURNT AND
URBAN FARMER AND THE
COORDINATOR OF THE RIVERSIDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT FOOD
HAVE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TEN OH NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATE MEMBER BLOOMIN IF WE
COULD- BEFORE WE GET TO-
WITNESSES MADAM SECRETARY GONNA
CALL THE ROLL SO BECAUSE THAT
WAS ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REVERSED. HERE MATHIS.
AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM LARA
GREAT- ONE JONES SAWYER PRESENT
LEVINE BUT THEY'RE PUT OFF HERE
WOOD. MEDIFARM DESIGNATE THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY AND SO-
WITH THAT OCTOBER I BELIEVE
BOTH WITNESSES WILL BECAUSE
FIND OVER THE PHONE- SO-
OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE-
CONNECT MISS DANIELS MISTER
BRANCH- WHO AGAIN WILL BE
TESTING IN SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
ZERO ZERO NINE- POLITANO. ARE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME YES WE ARE.
OKAY THANK YOU JERRY LET THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
THE CO FOUNDER OF THE CENTER
FOR GOOD FOOD PURCHASING. WE
DEVELOP A GOOD GOOD PERSON
PROGRAM WITHIN THE LOS ANGELES
FOOD POLICY COUNCIL WHICH I
FOUNDED TEN YEARS AGO IS AN
INITIATIVE THAT MAYOR BEATER
THAT SUCH AND I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TO TOP THE FINAL PART OF
THIS IMPORTANT BATTLE. I'M L.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WAS
AMONG THE FIRST TO ADOPT OUR
PROGRAM IN TWENTY TWELVE AND AS
A RESULT OF THAT IN ONE YEAR
THEY WENT FROM LESS THAN 10%
LOCAL SOURCING PRODUCE TO
NEARLY FIFTY PERCENT. SOMETHING
ABOUT TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
THE LOCAL FOOD ECONOMY AND
CREATING OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
NEW JOBS. I PROGRAM EXPANDED
NATIONALLY IT'S NOW HOUSING
CENTER WE WORK WITH FIFTY FOUR
INSTITUTIONS IN TWENTY ONE
CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING NEW YORK AND CHICAGO.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE OR IN
TWENTY TWO PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS.
FOURTEEN OF WHICH ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I NEED TO CALIFORNIA
TO. SPEND THE COME. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY. TO ON FOOD PER YEAR.
AND NOW DIRECTING AND- 16% OF
THAT THEIR LOCAL FOOD ECONOMIES.
SUPPORTING HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA LIVELIHOOD. THEY'D
LIKE TO AND CAN DO SO MUCH
MORE. ESPECIALLY TO SUPPORT THE
SMALLER FARMERS BETTER 80% OF
CALIFORNIANS. FARMING
POPULATION. BUT TO DO THAT THEY
NEED WHAT AB TEN OH NINE MAKES
POSSIBLE FARM TO SCHOOL
THROUGHOUT. BASED ON OUR
INTENSIVE RESEARCH OVER THE
PAST DECADE IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
FUNCTIONS WHO HAD SERVED. IN
CREATING A MORE DIRECT LINK AND
THE LOCAL SUPPLY CHAIN ARE THE
CRUCIAL MISSING PIECE. IN
HELPING LOCAL FARMERS REACHED
MARKETS AND LARGE INSTITUTIONS.
I GAVE A LOT MORE DETAIL THE
LETTER I SUBMITTED TO YOU ALL
ABOUT HOW MANY COULD HAVE THERE
ARE IN THE COUNTRY WHERE
WHICH INCLUDES MICHIGAN
MINNESOTA NEW YORK AND OHIO.
STATE AND OTHERS HE COULD HAVE
BEEN OTHER LOCAL PROJECTS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AS CRITICAL TO
THEIR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. AND
JOB CREATION STRATEGIES. THE
PRIMARY MAYBE TEN ON A OR ARE
REALLY AND- THAT PURPOSE AND
HAPPY CONNECT. SMALLER SOCIALLY
DIFFERENT AND SMART FARMERS
FIFTEEN. MARK AFTER. A LARGE.
LIKE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. BECAUSE
ALL KEY TO AN EQUITABLE
PANDEMIC ECONOMIC RECOVERY FOR
CALIFORNIANS FARMERS THE SHARES
OF THE PIE CHAIN RESILIENCE FOR
TEACHER CRISIS. SUPPORT CLIMATE
SMART PRODUCTION PRACTICES AND
FOR THE WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN BY
INCREASING ACCESS TO OUR
LOCALLY GROWN HEALTHY FOOD AND
ALSO LINKS WELL WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE WHICH YOU'LL BE HEARING
LATER. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM TRANSLATOR SHIP. THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR TESTIMONY AND
WITH THAT WILL MOVE TO MISTER
BURNT. HELLO MY NAME IS SCOTT
BURKE CAN YOU HEAR ME. LOUD AND
CLEAR. OKAY WHENEVER SCUPPERED
TIME THE FOOD- COORDINATOR FOR
THE RIVERSIDE FOOD JOB AND
URBAN FARMER THE RIVER SAID
FOOD HOPE IS THE CDFA IN USDA
GRANT FUNDED ENTITY OF
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT NUTRITION SERVICES THE
RIVERSIDE FOOD HELP WAS A PILOT
PROJECT TO DETERMINE THE
FEASIBILITY OF OPERATING A FOOD
HUB UTILIZE AN EXISTING SCHOOL
INFRASTRUCTURE. PUT OBSERVER
MISSION DRIVEN ARGUE. AIM TO
AGGREGATING PRODUCE FROM
SMALLER FARMS AND PROVIDING
MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT TO LOCAL
FARMING ECONOMIES. THE
REQUESTED FOOD UP IS NOT ONLY
GRANT FUNDED BUT RECEIVES
TREMENDOUS IN KIND SUPPORT FROM
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT INCLUDING
TRUCKS WAREHOUSE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND COUNTY THE MINISTRY TO
BRIDGEPORT SUPPORT. WITHOUT
THIS GRANT AND IN KIND SUPPORT
THE FOOD WOULD NOT BE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE. UNLIKE
MAJOR FOOD DISTRIBUTION OF TWO
THAT HAVE HIGH PROFIT MARGINS.
TIONAL DISTRIBUTION CHANNELS
ONLY RETURNED ELEVEN CENTS TO
THE FARMERS FOR EVERY DOLLAR IN
SALES WELL OF FOOD- WILL RETURN
7290% 90% OF EACH SALES DOLLAR
TO FARMERS. IMPORTANTLY FOOD
HERBS ARE COMMUNITY FOCUSED IN
BETTER THAN A LOCAL FARMER
NETWORK AND HAVE THE MARKET
INFRASTRUCTURE CAPACITY WITH
SMALL SCALE FARMERS DON'T HAVE.
FOR EXAMPLE DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE RIVER
SAID FOOD I WAS ABLE TO QUICKLY
PIVOT AND DISTRIBUTE ALMOST A
HUNDRED. THOUSAND EMERGENCY
FOOD BOXES BECAUSE OF THESE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS. SMALL
AND MEDIUM SPECIALTY CROP
FARMERS ARE INDEPENDENT AND
SELF RELIANT AND ARE NOT
LOOKING FOR HANDOUTS OR
SUBSIDIES THEY JUST WANTED
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM THAT WORKS
IN THEIR FAVOR. AND FOOD HAS
WILL PROVIDE DECAL EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION FOR THEM SO
STRONGLY SUPPORT SUCH AS YOUR
SUPPORT SUPPORT SUPPORT OF THE
THIRD OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THE BILL. YEAH HIS MOTION
SECONDED SO- WITH THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- FOR THIS BILL-
THEREFORE THERE'S NO I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- AND SO ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISCIBLE. THE NOT I
WORK ON SOME MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR BRING THIS PART I'VE TRIED
THIS A COUPLE OF TIMES AND THIS
NEEDS TO GET THROUGH IT SO
IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN TO HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES IS WHAT BILLS
WELL UP TEARS FOR THE FARMERS-
I WILL BE SUPPORTING A BILL
TODAY AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE A
CO AUTHOR. IF I'M NOT ALREADY.
HE WILL DOUBLE CHECK. WELCOME
ABOARD. AT MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE SEE NOW WILL MOVE TO
OP. PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
MEMBERS. HERE WOULD LIKE TO
PRIDE TO COMMONSENSE TIME TO DO
SO. C. NINE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATE ARE THERE
ANY- CALLERS IN THE QUEUE. TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE ZERO ZERO NINE. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL COLORS AND- THIS
TIME WE WILL FIRST GO TO LINE
THIRTY FOUR GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
MARK. THANK YOU FROM OF ANIMAL
CONSERVATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE SEVEN. ONE SEVEN GO AHEAD.
ONE SEVEN IF YOU DO WANT TO
QUIT TO- VOICE YOUR OPINION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONCE AGAIN
WILL GO NEXT TO LINE THIRTY TWO.
NINE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY JUSTIN RATHER ON
BEHALF OF RICHARD CHANGE ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IT. NINE
FORTY SIX I CANNOT SHOW THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT. LINE THIRTY
ONE. DAVE RENTON COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY HEY
THIS IS ELENA BROKE- BUT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE FORTY FIVE. HI
THIS IS AMBER CAN VISITING FROM
THE EARTH TODAY FORCING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB ONE ZERO ZERO
NINE THANK YOU. THIS TEACHER WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN DO IT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU- AND- WITH
THAT WE HAVE A- MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I YOUR CAREER
SECOND BY THE NUMBER VIA. WHO
WHO WHO ARE- MISTER BLOOM
REALLY APPRECIATE- THIS
LEGISLATION I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND- VERY THANKFUL
THAT- YOU CURRENT THIS BILL AND
SO WITH THAT- DO YOU WANNA
CLOSE. THANK IMAGES MISTER
CHAIR WITH RESPECT I ASK YOUR
ARRIVAL. TIME THAT MA'AM
SECRETARY CAN YOU. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I DON'T WANT AB ONE
OH OH NINE BLOOM OF MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS HI RIVAS
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM FLORA LARA I AGREE-
ONE HI IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I'VE BE UPLOAD WA THE
UPPER WALL I WOULD. THAT'S
SEVEN SEVEN BUCKS CONTEST THE
BILL'S OUT THANK YOU CENTER
WILL THANK YOU. OKAY AND SO-
SEE HERE WHERE I'M AT SO WITH
THAT WE HAVE THE NEXT IN THE
FILE ORDER- ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MEGAN DOLLY WITH- SHE'LL BE ANY
TWO BILLS TODAY FIRST BEING
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIX SIX-
AND- PRIOR TO. THAT
PRESENTATION I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT- BY THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST
ON TODAY'S AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ONE OR
ONE TWO EIGHT NINE HAS BEEN
PULLED OFF TODAY'S AGENDA SO
WITH THAT MS DAHLE INSIDERS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB EIGHT SIXTY SIX PROVIDES THE
SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AG. GIVE.
THE CLASS RIVAL. THE WASHINGTON
TIMES. WHAT HAS BEEN THE TYPES
OF LABORATORIES THAT MAYBE IT
UTILIZED FOR TESTING AND
ANALYZING AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS
SUCH AS ANIMAL FEED AND SEEDS
TAKE ANY STEPS TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY TURN AROUND TIME AND
PROVIDE COST SAVING IN BOTH
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM TO
FARMERS AND- CONSUMERS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS ONLY ONE CD
OF IT F. A LABORATORY PROVIDING
FEE FOR SERVICE PURITY AND
GERMINATION TESTING ANALYSIS
PROCEEDS SERVICE. PROGRAMS THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE GOVERNMENT
AND COMMERCIAL LABORATORIES WE
CAN PROVIDE EQUIVALENT. LEVELS
OF PURITY AND GERMINATION
TESTING AND ANALYSIS. HERE WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS DONNA BOGGS
ASSOCIATION I'M DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
AND ELAINE TREVINO PRESIDENT OF
THE ON AN ALLIANCE. OF
CALIFORNIA. AND DOES IT THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALITS
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE.
CONNECT MISS BOGGS AND MISSED
TRIVINO GO AGAIN WILL BE
PROVIDING AS IT DOES WHEN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT SIX SIX.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS
WEEKEND. YES GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DONNA BOXMAN THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
ONE OF THE BILL'S SPONSORS. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE'S PLANT PEST
DIAGNOSTIC CENTER HAS BEEN THE
SOLE PROVIDER OF REGULATORY FEE
FOR SERVICE TESTING AND
ANALYSIS FOR THE SEATS SERVICES
PROGRAM FOR DECADES. THE CDFA
LAB PROVIDES TESTING AND
ANALYSIS TO SUPPORT COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL SEED
PURITY AND GERMINATION
STANDARDS. AB EIGHT SIXTY SIX
IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE THE SECRETARY
OF CDFA WITH ANOTHER TOOL IN
THE TOOLBOX TO APPROVE OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AND COMMERCIAL
LABORATORIES TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY TESTING AND ANALYSIS
TO THE SEED SERVICES PROGRAM.
TAKING NEW STEPS WILL PROVIDE
THE SECRETARY WITH THE ABILITY
TO EXPAND LABORATORY CAPACITY
FOR THE SEEDS SERVICES PROGRAM
INCREASE EFFICIENCY TURN AROUND
TIME AND PROVIDE COST SAVINGS
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU.
DID YOU MISS BOX. I THANK YOU
MS BOX FOR THOSE COMMENTS-
MISSED TRIVINO. ARE YOU ONLINE.
I AM ENTERING GERMANY THAT
MEMBERS OF. MY NAME IS ELAINE
TREVINO I REPRESENT THE-
ALLIANCE THAT CALIFORNIA WHERE
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALMOND INDUSTRY AND
OUR INDUSTRY RELIES ON
EFFICIENT AND RAPID TURNAROUND
A LAB RESULTS OF ARE ON THE
WHOLE SAMPLES THAT ARE USED FOR
GUARANTEED. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE GREATER EFFICIENCY AND
FASTER LAB RESULTS TURN AROUND
FIND. SO FOR THAT REASON ALONE
WE APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
SPELL AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY
EVER DOLLY FOR CARRYING THE
SPELLING RESPECT AID REQUEST
YOUR I FELT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MYSTERY NO- THERE'S
NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION FOR
THIS BILL AND SO WITH THAT I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO- THE- THE TO
THE MEMBERS THEY QUESTIONS. C.
NINE I WILL OPEN UP FOR US A
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S ANY
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE WE
SHOULD MAKE COMMENTS NOT TIME
TO DO SO. SEE NON OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
ARE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
QUEUE- WANTED TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL. COMMENTS
ON THIS BILL PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU'LL HEAR
AN INDICATION BEEN PLACED INTO
Q. AN EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST
WILL PROVIDE YOU AND YOUR
NUMBER LINE NUMBER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER OPERATOR AND SO WITH
THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SOME OF OUR FLOOR A SECOND BY
MISTER MATHIS. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DAHLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT. ALL
RIGHT MATTIS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON ITEM TO ABC
EIGHT SIXTY SIX AMERICAN DOLLY-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REFRESH HI RIVAS AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA LARA I
AGREE- ONE IRWIN AYE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I'D BE A PUT OFF WE HAVE
FOOD RAW I WOULD. WITH NINE
ZERO ALL RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT-
IS DOLLY- FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE OR SECOND BILLS ON THE
BILL ONE ONE ZERO THREE. THANK
YOU. AB ELEVEN OH THREE CREATES
A STANDARDIZED TRAINING AND
FRAMEWORK FOR AGRICULTURAL PAST
PROGRAM ALLOWING FARMERS AND
RANCHERS TO ACCESS THEIR
PROPERTY IN EMERGENCY TO SAVE
THEIR LIVESTOCK AND LANDS WHAT
ABOUT WILDFIRES THREATEN
COMMERCIAL FARMING AND RANCHING
OPERATIONS ROAD CLOSURES OFTEN
PREVENT RANCHERS FROM DOCTOR IN
THERE IN ALMOST PROVIDING THEM
ESSENTIAL WATER AND FEED OR
EVACUATING THEM FORMER DOES HE
RESPOND AS A VOLUNTEER GROUPS
CAN ASSIST IN RESCUING
HOUSEHOLD PETS AND A FEW LARGE
ANIMALS. THEY LACK THE RANGERS
EXPERTISE NECESSARY TO HANDLE
LARGE ANIMALS OR CATTLE OR
OTHER LIVESTOCK TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE AND HOW RURAL COMMUNITIES
PREPARE FOR WILDFIRES COUNTY
SUCH AS VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA HAVE BEGAN DEVELOPING
AN ACT PASSED PROGRAM WHICH
TRAINS FARMERS AND RANCHERS AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IDENTIFY
THOSE TRAINED AGRICULTURE'S TO
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL AG PASSED
PROGRAM ENABLES EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS TO PROVIDE RANCHERS
ACCESS TO THEIR PROPERTY TO
READ TO TREAT AND RESCUE
ANIMALS AND FACILITATE THREE
INTEREST PROVIDING SUPPORT. TO
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL SUCH AS
IDENTIFYING ACCESS ROADS AND
WATER SOURCES AG PRESS PROGRAMS
ARE NOT WIDESPREAD IN
CALIFORNIA IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE SIGNIFICANT EFFORT REQUIRED
FOR COUNTY TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM WITH NO STANDARD I'D
PROGRAMMER TRAINING COUNTIES
MUST DEVELOP THEM ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS WHICH IS TIME
CONSUMING AND COSTLY A. B.
ELEVEN OH THREE AS A SOLUTION
AND ROOM WILL REQUIRE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO ESTABLISH A
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK IN
TRAINING. FOR AN AG PASSED
PROGRAM COVERING FIRE BEHAVIOR
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO AG
HOUSEHOLDER EXCEPT IN CERTAIN
SPECIFIED CIRCUMSTANCES AND
MUCH OF THE PRESS PASS HOLDERS
ARE CURRENTLY ABLE TO ACCESS
RESTRICTED AREAS DURING
EMERGENCY I AM CURRENTLY IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
REGARDING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
CLARIFY THE PASSES ARE INTENDED
FOR AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS
RATHER THAN EMPLOYEES TO
ENSURE. WORKERS PROTECTIONS AND
ADDRESS AND ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES RAISED I AM COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
AS IS BILLS DOUBLE REFERRED TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND TODAY WE HAVE WITH A TO
TEST IS THE OF THE BILL IS
MATTHEW SO. FIVE AND RANGE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATION EXTENSION OF
VENTURA COUNTY. AND ANTHONY-
STORE NOT A BATTALION CHIEF
FROM SANTA BARBARA COUNTY FIRE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY. MEMBER DOLLY
AND SO WITH THAT- BOTH WITH%
THIS IS WHICH IS FINE- THE
PHONE OPERATOR IF. YOU WOULD
PLEASE. CONNECT MR SHAPIRO AND
MR STARR NETTA. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MATTHEW SHAPIRO WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO BEGIN. YES
PLEASE. GREAT SO AGAIN MY NAME
IS MATTHEW SHAPIRO AND I
SERVICE THE LIVESTOCK AND RANGE
OF BY THEIR FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION IN VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES MY COMMENTS
TODAY HOWEVER ARE MINE ALONE
AND DO NOT REFLECT THE OFFICIAL
POSITION OF THE UNIVERSITY. MY
TENURE WITH THE EXTENSION OF
THE DEFINED BY WILDFIRE IS JUST
MONTHS AFTER I STARTED IN MY
JOB THE THOMAS FIRE BURNED
THROUGH NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF RANGELAND MY
TO COUNTIES- DURING THE THOMAS
FIRE THAT I FIRST BECAME AWARE
OF THE VENTURA COUNTY ACT.
PROGRAMS LIKE COMMITTEE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE INTERESTS IT'S IN
AND ABOUT THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE. AND IS DUST UNIQUELY
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRE. RUN
ESSENTIALLY IF THE LOCAL AD HOC
PROGRAM THE AG PASSING VENTURA
HAS LONG RELIED ON PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FIRE AGENCIES IN
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY. IN
THE WAKE OF THE THOMAS FIRE MY
COLLEAGUE MAX MARTIN I PRODUCED
PUBLICATION THAT LEANED ON
VENTURA COUNTY'S EXPERIENCES
WITH THE ACT PASSED. AND
PROVIDED A BLUEPRINT FOR HOW
OTHER COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
MIGHT ESTABLISH A SIMILAR
PROGRAM. THE RESPONSE HAS BEEN
JUST TREMENDOUS. AND MANY
COUNTY THEY'RE EXPRESSING
STRONG INTEREST TO ADOPT ACT
PASSED CONCEPT. IN OUR SUMMARY
DR MORE TONIGHT AND DECIDED
THAT GIVEN THE UNIQUE
GEOGRAPHIC IN ADMINISTRATIVE
CONSTRAINTS OF EACH COUNTING.
THAT THE ACT PASSES REALLY BEST
SUITED FOR LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION. WITH THAT SAID
HOWEVER WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
HAVING A GUIDING STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK WHICH HAS BEEN
CRITICAL AND MEETING FULLY
BANDAGES TO ENSURING THAT THE
STATE'S. CONSISTENT AND FAIR
PROGRAM COULD BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO ALL AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS
IN CALIFORNIA. I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE FOR THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BASED ON MY
EXPERTISE TO THE LIVESTOCK AND
RANGE BY THERE. AND ANSWER
QUESTION. SHOULD THERE BE ANY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SHE-
MISTER STORE NOW. IF YOU ARE
READY TO GO. I FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN. YES GOOD MORNING TERRY
THIS MEMBERS OF THE R. COSTA
COMMITTEE MONEY MISSING AT
LEAST ONE OTHER- A BIT
GENERATION CATTLE RANCHER INSALES THAT'S WHAT COUNTY AND
I'M REPRESENTING- CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION TO BE
IN THE FIRE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
ALSO A LITTLE MORE UNIQUE SEEN
BOTH SIDES OF THE STORY I'M A
BATTALION CHIEF WITH SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT
I OVERSEE ALL THE ERROR WHILE
IN OPERATION AND IN THE FIRE
SERVICE FOR TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
ALONG THOSE THAT TIME LINE
WE'VE SEEN IN MANY OF YOUR
LOWER THIS CATASTROPHIC FIRES
IN CALIFORNIA RESPONDING TO A
MAJORITY OF THOSE FIRES WHICH
I'VE SEEN IN THE NEED OF ASK
DEVELOPING PARTNERSHIPS WORKING
TOGETHER AND TAKE A CLEVER
APPROACH TO MINIMIZE LIVESTOCK-
CROP DAMAGE AND HUMAN LIFE AND
IS MENTIONED EARLIER THE
CALIFORNIA KARAKHANIDS OVER
FIFTY BILLION SO WORKING
TOGETHER ON ALL THESE PART IT
TAKES ALL HANDS ON DECK TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN WITH THIS NEW ACT
PASSED PROPOSAL. WE PURPOSELY
SEEKING A BUYER SIDE A LITTLE
BETTER HELLO DELETING OF
ACCESS- WITH THE ACT PASSED
CARD IN THE CARD HOLDERS WE CAN
TRACK THOSE PEOPLE AND WITH THE
PROPOSAL BUT NOT THREE THERE'S
ALSO MANDATED TRAINING WHICH
RIGHT NOW YOU MAY THINK THERE'S
COURSE EVACUATION TEAM TO GO
OUT THERE IT'S NOT A
REQUIREMENT FOR TRAINING SO WE
WANT TO PUT THIS INTO A STATE
CURRICULUM MUCH LIKE WE
FACILITATED UNDER THE CURRENT
DEVELOPMENT OF SENATE BILL
TWELVE SIXTY AND THE BURN BOSS
PROGRAM IS WE WANT EVERYONE TO
BE ON THE SAME PAGE AND I'VE
REACHED OUT. MYSTICAL LEGENDARY
BEING CONSUMER COUNTY WORK LONG
PORTION RIGHT OFF RIGHT OFF THE
GET GO SAME THING WITH THAT
COMMISSIONER AND THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT I'VE REACHED OUT
ACROSS THE STATE TO THE OTHER
ORGANIZATION SUCH AS CAL FIRE
CHP AND GOT INPUT FROM THEM AS
WELL AND THE MAIN THING IS
CONSISTENCY ONE A CARD THAT
EVERYONE CAN RECOGNIZE AND SEE
AN ACCOUNT FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS- WE JUST WANT TO
TAKE THAT COLOR POACHING
THERE'S BEEN MANY PARTNERSHIPS
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN. A BIT OF AND IT'S PART OF LIKE THE
WILD HIGH RESILIENCE ACTION
PLAN A PRESCRIBED FIRE
INVOLVING HAZARDOUS FUEL FROM
THE SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY
THIS IS JUST ONE MORE STEP WERE
THE AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY THE
FIRE SERVICE ALONG PARTS THAT.
CAN COME TOGETHER AND HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL WELL- I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL IS. AND LIKE
DESCRI EARLIER I'M AVAILABLE.
FOR ANY TYPE OF QUESTIONS OR
ANY PROTOCOL NOT LIKE. ALSO
THANK US. MEMBER DAHLE PERSON.
THIS THANK YOU. AT THE VERY
CONSCIOUS STRAIN AND- WE DO
HAVE- THE WITNESS BE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITE. AND CAN'T. I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RULE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- MISS
KATTAN IF YOU ARE WITH US. YOU
ARE WELCOME TO BEGIN. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR RIVAS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM AN ACCOUNTANT WORK
HEALTH AND SAFETY SPECIALIST
WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- TO START
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS WILLINGNESS
TO TRY TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT AB ELEVEN OH THREE AND TO
NARROW THE POOL OF EMPLOYEES.
ALLOWED TO WORK IN EVACUATION
ZONES AND WE DO RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF THE UNIFORMS STATE
PROCESS FOR GRANTING PASSES TO
AG PRODUCERS- AND HAVING
ACCOMPANYING TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS WITH THAT. HOWEVER
WE ARE OPPOSED TO GRANTING
PASSES THAT ALLOW ANY EMPLOYEES
OF FARMS AND RANCHES INCLUDING
MANAGERIAL EMPLOYEES TO WORK
INSIDE EVACUATION ZONES.
BECAUSE THESE WORKERS SHOULD
NOT BE ASKED TO WORK OR ALLOWED
TO WORK IN AREAS DEEMED UNSAFE
FOR THE PUBLIC. ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE GOING IN WITHOUT
FIGHTER ESCORT- AND- IN A WITH
DUE RESPECT- WE THINK THAT
COMPARING THE BILL'S ACCESS
PROVISIONS TO THE GRANTING OF
PASSES TO THE PRESS ISN'T AN
APPROPRIATE COMPARISON BECAUSE
MEMBERS OF THE PRESS AREN'T
WORKING. WITHIN THE EVACUATION.
AND A COMMITMENT- WE ARE ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT TO THE PENAL CODE IN
THIS BILL SKEWS ME. THAT WOULD
ALLOW AG PASSHOLDERS ACCESS TO
EVACUATION ZONES UNTIL RISK
RISES TO THE LEVEL OF IMMINENT
HARM. EXPERIENCE HAS SHOWN THAT
WILDFIRES CAN EXPAND RAPIDLY
AND THIS HIGH BAR FOR EXCLUDING
PASSHOLDERS LEAVES NO MARGIN
FOR SAFETY- INSTEAD WE THINK
LAW ENFORCEMENT OR FIRE
PERSONNEL SHOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO REFUSE ENTRY TO
ACT PASS HOLDERS- IF THEY JUDGE
IT IS UNSAFE TO ENTER- IN
CLOSING- WITHOUT FURTHER
AMENDMENT TO EXCLUDE ALL
EMPLOYEES. FROM THE AG PASS
PROGRAM AND- AMENDMENT TO ALLOW
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE
PERSONNEL TO EXERCISE THEIR
JUDGMENT ON WHEN TO ALLOW-
ACCESS WE URGENT NO VOTE THANK
YOU. THIS CAN APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS- AND SO WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. AYE SIR MATHIS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER DALI I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORMAT ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
DOING A SIMILAR THING- SO I'D
LIKE TO JOIN AUTHOR THIS WITH
YOU- TO THE CONCERNS THAT I
HEARD OF VOICE THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF DOING THIS PROGRAM
AND DOING THE TRAINEES. IS TO
ENSURE THAT- THESE THESE FOLKS
GOING INTO THESE AREAS. DO YOU
HAVE THE TRAINING AND THE
CAUTIONARY ABILITIES TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY ARE GOING
INTO- WE'VE SEEN TOO MUCH LOSS
OF LIFE- FOR ANIMALS FOR
LIVESTOCK DURING THESE FIRE
SITUATIONS AND THIS WILL HELP
MITIGATE THAT. AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT FORWARD
AND LIKE TO JOIN AUTHORED WITH
TRAVIS ALLEN THANK YOU THANK.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LAST
SCENE THAT WILL MOVE ON TO SOME
PUBLIC COMMENT- THERE'S A
MEMBERS IN THIS ROOM WHO WOULD.
LIKE TO MAKE THE COMMENTS AS
TIME TO DO SO. LONGER ENBREL.
I'M SUPPORT AND- DRIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I SEE NO OTHER
COME IN THIS ROOM- OPERATOR- DO
WE HAVE ANY BECAUSE OF THE
QUEUE TO. MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON
THIS LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE ONE ZERO THREE FOUR COVER.
FOR COMMENTS ON THIS
LEGISLATION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LIVE THIRTY NINE QUIET PLACE.
YEAH COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS
WITH THIS BRANCH OF ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK WE ARE IN A
SUPPORT AS AMENDED PETITION ON
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY. BUT
YOU WANNA EXPRESS THEIR
APPRECIATION TO SPONSOR AFTER
THEIR COLLABORATION AND WORKINGWITH US ON AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY. OF THE PROJECT
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND I THINK HE AND I
WILL KEEP YOU PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE WINE INSTITUTE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THIS TEACHER
THERE NO FURTHER- VINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME FANTASTIC
THANK YOU MISTER OPERATOR- AND
SO. WITH THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE LEGISLATION
YEAH OBVIOUSLY- THERE ARE. SOME
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
THAT THEY ARE IMPORTANT ONES
THAT REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT. TO WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- TO. HOPEFULLY
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS MOVING
FORWARD. BUT SO THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE LEARNED ABOUT
WHEN WE HAD A INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON WILDFIRE IN
NOVEMBER. SO APPRECIATE- THE-
EFFORT TO ADDRESS IT. AND SO
WIT THAT- I KNOW THAT WE DO
HAVE A- MOTION BY- VICE CHAIR
MATHIS AND- SECOND BY SOME A
MEMBER. CUNNINGHAM I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE SALAS. YES THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WERE HEADED
INTO YET ANOTHER DEVASTATING
WILDFIRE SEASON. AND I THINK WE
ALL- READ THE ACCOUNT OF DAVID
DAVIES. OUR DAILY EXCUSE ME WHO
LOST. HUNDREDS OF COWS. AND
IT'S JUST A DEBIT IT
DEVASTATING EXPERIENCE AND IN.
THIS IS GROUND THEY KNOW AND
THEY KNOW WHILE. AND OF COURSE
THEY WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED IN
PASSED THE LINE IF IT WASN'T
SAFE AND IT IS THE BILL'S
INTENDED FOR. THOSE
AGRICULTURE. PRODUCERS NOT
THEIR EMPLOYEES SO WE ARE GOING
TO WORK TO NARROW THAT AND TO
ALLEVIATE ANY CONCERNS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. THANK YOU AND I
THINK WE'VE EVER HAD A QUESTION
FROM SUMMER AGUILAR. YEAH
CURRY- I'M IN ALREADY FOR THE
BILL ARE YOU TAKE A AMENDMENTS
AND EMERGED BAN- WE'RE WORKING
THAT I INTO INTO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE BUT WE WILL BE TAKING
MEASUREMENTS OKAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH THAT MEMSIC TAKING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON ITEM
THREE AB ELEVEN OH THREE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS.
RIVERSIDE MATHIS MATHIS HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA
LARA I AGREE IRWIN IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE HI LEVINE IVF WOULD ROCK
BE A GOOD WHILE I WOULD. AT
NINE BILLS THANK YOU. THE
NUMBER OF THREE DAY THANK YOU.
SO PROBABLY THE NEXT BILL YEAH
YOU HAVE ONE OF DR- THE ROLE
FOR THE TWENTY FOR ANYONE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS SESSION
TODAY- RIGHT. BY THE NUMBER OF
RECORDS AND LYFT MATHIS- HELLO.
ON THE ASSEMBLY ARE COMMITTEE
RULES FOR TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
LETTERS SIDE OR SOME MEMBER
READ. RIVAS I MATHIS MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI FLORA
LARA I AGREE- IRWIN- IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE LEVINE IDEA PUT OFF
THEIR FOOD WHILE I WOULD- THE
RULES ARE ADOPTED. A ONE DOLLAR
THEY THE- EXACTLY. BY THE
SECOND BY THE IDYLLWILD RIGHT.
ON THE CONSENT CAL SOME MEMBER
READ. ALL OF RIVAS HIGH MATT
THIS MATHIS I AGREE.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA. OR I IRWIN-
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LEVINE. LEVINE IDEA PUT OFF
THEIR FOOD WHILE I WOULD. THAT
HAS NINE VOTES THANK YOU HAVE
SECRETARY. WITH THAT FILE ITEM
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA BE PRESENTED SIMPLY BILL
SEVEN ONE ZERO. WELCOME SOME
THE NUMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES- JUST WANT
TO START BY EMPHASIZINGHOW
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPORTANT A. B.
SEVEN TENNIS TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION- FOR US
TODAY AND FOR THE YEARS TO COME
THE RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE IS TAKING ACTION TO
GUARANTEE TO HELP THE SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. AND
AGRICULTURE FILL WORKERS BY
ENSURING THE USE OF SAFE
CHEMICALS AND PROVIDING
ECONOMIC FREEDOM BY ENSURING
THAT THE RIGHT TO A LIVING
WAGE- THAT MEETS BASIC
HOUSEHOLD NEEDS IS MET. FARMERS
IN THIS STATE PRODUCE FRUITS
VEGETALES NUTS AND MEATS FROM
ANIMAL LIVESTOCK IN ACCORDANCE
WITH STATE PESTICIDE LABOR AND
MINIMUM WAGE LAWS COMPLYING
WITH THE STATE LAWS WITHOUT A
DOUBT WE'VE HEARD INCREASES
COST PROVIDES REAL BENEFITS TO
THE HEALTH OF CONSUMERS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND TO THE WORKERS
WHO PRODUCE THESE GOODS. AB
SEVEN TEN WOULD REQUIRE CERTAIN
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS SOLD TO
THE PUBLIC TO BE PRODUCED IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR STATE
REGULATIONS THIS BILL WOULD
PLACE OUR PESTICIDE REGULATIONS
ON THE LISTED OUT OF STATE
PRODUCE AND OUR LABOR
REGULATIONS ON THE LISTED OUT
OF STATE. COUNTRY PRODUCED THIS
BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THE
FOLLOWING PRODUCE FRESH OR
VALUE ADDED FRESH APPLES
SPARGO'S BELL PEPPERS
BLUEBERRIES DATES HONEYDEW
MELONS LEMONS NECTARINES OLIVES
AND TABLE GRAPES I CAN SHARE
WITH YOU HOW WE CAME UP WITH
THAT LIST IF NEED BE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CONCERNS
WITH THE ABILITY FOR GROCERY
STORES TO SOURCE THESE PRODUCTS
YEAR ROUND. BUT WE SPECIFICALLY
CHOSE THESE LIST OF PRODUCTS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM IF NOT
ALL ARE GROWN YEAR ROUND HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHILE PRODUCTS
LIKE APPLES ARE NOT IN SEASON
YEAR ROUND THE OPEN MARKET AND
OUR FARMERS HAVE ADDRESSED THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO ADJUST TO
THOSE NEEDS. AN APPLE FARMER IN
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON OR
CHILE IT CAN TAP INTO A MARKET
ALL THEY WOULD HAVE TO DO IS
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
THEIR WORKERS. AND CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS THE- OF A HEALTHY AND
SAFE SOCIETY. IS A HUMAN RIGHT
AND THE LEGISLATURE CAN SHOW
ITS COMMITMENT TO SAFEGUARDING
THAT IDEAL. BY INSURING THEIR
PRODUCE SOLD IN THE STATE MEETS
THOSE SAME EXPECTATIONS THAT WE
PUT ON OUR OWN FARMERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE QUESTION WE
MUST ASK OURSELVES. IS WHY DO
WE PUT THESE REGULATIONS ON OUR
FARMERS. AND I THINK IT'S
SIMPLE. THE ANSWER IS A TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
OUR- CONSUMERS- THE WORKERS.
AND PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
ADOPTED THESE REGULATIONS TO
PURPOSELY HURT OUR FARMERS BUT
CLEARLY WE'VE HEARD. THAT IT
HAS. CAUSED A SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC BURDEN TO SOME. FOR US
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL. IS
VERY CLEAR. IT'S ABOUT ENSURING
THAT THE PRODUCTS SOLD IN THE
STATE ME CALIFORNIA'S
EXPECTATIONS ON HEALTH AND
SAFETY. AND HUMAN RIGHTS OUT
WITH THAT I WANT TO TELL YOU
THAT- TRULY BELIEVE THAT- WE
HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY HERE.
TO UPHOLD THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA. AS A
TOP PRIORITY AND MAKING SURE
THAT AGAIN WE NEED THOSE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. GOALS THAT WE SET
EVERY SINGLE DAY WHEN WE PROVE
PUBLIC POLICY HERE. OUT WE HAVE
TO WITNESSES- THE FIRST IS
ANTHONY BIANCO. WHO IS A
LIFELONG FARMER IN THE
COACHELLA IMPERIAL AND CENTRAL
VALLEY. THE SECOND IS THAT NONE
AND ON THIS YEAH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER
FOUNDATION. RESEARCHER. AND
TESSLER. MOTION BY SAMANTHA-
IT'S A WITH THAT A PRE. THE
TESTIMONY SOME A MEMBER
OPERATOR WE PLEASE MAKE SURE
TOO THAT WE- CONNECT MR BIANCO
MISTER HERNANDEZ AND IF THEY
ARE AVAILABLE NOW- PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO A- TO START. IT IS A
HALFPENNY BIANCO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN I'M ANTHONY BIANCO
THE CO OWNER OF ANTHONY
VINEYARDS WITH OPERATIONS IN
BOTH COACHELLA AND CENTRAL
VALLEY. AB SEVEN TEN IS A
CALIFORNIA FARM WORKER BUILT A
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL BILL
THE CALIFORNIA FARMER BILL
MAYBE THE FIRST TIME IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY THAT THESE
THREE GROUPS HAVE JOINED FORCES
TO GET BEHIND ONE BILL. AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS ENSURED
THE FARM WORKERS RECEIVE A
LIVING WAGE AND THAT THE
ENVIRONMENT IS PROTECTED
GROWERS COSTS HAVE GONE UP
DRAMATICALLY AND WE HAVE SEEN
HIGHER LABOR COSTS LIKE THESE
LISTED IN THE BILL. THAT WILL
SOON NO LONGER BE PRODUCED AND
THIS IS LEADING TO A DRAMATIC
LOSS IN FARMWORKERS JOBS AT A
LOSS IN CROP DIVERSITY FAR
STATES GROWERS. BUT OTHER
STATES AND COUNTRIES ARE NOW
CAPITALIZING ON OUR STATE'S
BRAVE LEADERSHIP AND SAFETY
LIVING WAGES. FOR INSTANCE FOR
NEARLY FORTY YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN REDUCING THE CHEMICALS
GROWERS CAN USE OUR CROPS WE
ARE FREELY GIVEN THREE REASONS
FOR IT NUMBER ONE THE CHEMICALS
ARE HAZARDOUS FOR THE
FARMWORKERS REPLY IT GREAT
REASON. NUMBER TWO THE
CHEMICALS ARE NOT GOOD FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT ANOTHER GREAT
REASON NUMBER THREE THE
CHEMICALS ARE DANGEROUS TO
CONSUME. FANTASTIC REASON
HOWEVER THESE THROUGH THESE
SAME CHEMICALS ARE STILL USE
GLOBALLY IN EVERY OTHER STATE
AND THEN WE ALLOW THE STATE'S
AND COUNTRY'S DIFFERENTLY SHIP
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES CONTAIN
THESE VERY CHEMICALS. APPLIED
BY FARMWORKERS AND SOAKED INTO
THEIR GROUND UNDERCUTTING OUR
PRICES COSTING FARMWORKERS JOBS
AND TO BE CONSUMED BY
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT CLOSING
THIS BACK DOOR WE ARE NOT ONLY
UNDER CUTTING OUR STATE'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY WE'RE
ALSO PUTTING CALIFORNIANS AT
RISK. THIS BILL DOES NOT SAVE
ALL CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS JOBS
AND WILL NOT SAVE ALL
CALIFORNIA FARMS BUT IT WILL
ENSURE THAT MANY CALIFORNIA
FARM WORKERS AND GROWERS WILL
CONTINUE SUPPLYING OUR STATE
WITH THESE PRODUCTS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY AND THAT THESE
PRODUCTS WILL REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA VALUES. EVERY TIME
ONE OF THESE PRODUCTS IS BOUGHT
AND CONSUMED IN CALIFORNIA YOU
WILL KNOW THAT THE FORMER CREW
HAD THEIR HANDS ON IT RECEIVED
A LIVING WAGE AND. THAT THE
ENVIRONMENT WAS FULLY PROTECTED.
ALL OF THESE TEN. ARE PRODUCED
EXPENSE AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THIS IS ONLY TEN PRODUCTS. THE
BUYERS WILL TELL YOU THE PRICES
WILL RISE AND SHELVES WILL NOT
BE STOPPED THAT IS NOT THE
CASE. AND HUGE MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR MULTINATIONAL COMPANIES
WILL BE FIGHTING THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THEY KEEP **** KEEP
SELLING OUT OF COUNTRY PRODUCT
IN MAKING THEIR 60% ALL ALL
CONTRIBUTING NOTHING TO OUR
FARMWORKERS JOBS INTO OUR
ECONOMY. FAR WORKING IS A
STEPPING STONE TO A BETTER
LIFE. AN ENTRY POINT TO THE
AMERICAN DREAM THERE IS A NEW
GENERATION OF FARMER CALIFORNIA
ONE WHO CARES DEEPLY FOR THE
FARM WORKERS WHO MAKE OUR
INDUSTRY RUN. AND ALSO CARES
PASSIONATELY FOR SHARED
ENVIRONMENT AND I AM ONE OF
THEM. CALIFORNIA FARMWORKERS
AND MYSELF RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR YES VOTE ON AB SEVEN TEN
THANK YOU. MISTER BARAK
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MISTER
HERNANDEZ IF YOU ARE READY TO
GO FOR IS ALL YOURS. YES THANK
YOU MR THE CALIFORNIA FORMATIVE
FOUNDATION SUPPORTS LEGISLATION
THAT EXPANDS PROTECTION FOR
FARMWORKERS THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. ALL WORK IS
STILL NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS AB SEVEN TEN THIRTY
STANDS FOR THE IMPORTATION OF
CERTAIN CROPS INTO CALIFORNIA.
THE STANDARDS ARE BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S GLOBALLY
RECOGNIZED PESTICIDE AND FIFTY
STANDARDS AND ENSURE THE
PROTECTIONS AFFORDED TO
FARMWORKERS HERE AND ALSO APPLY
TO FARMWORKERS OUTSIDE OF OUR
STATE. AB SEVEN TEN ALSO ENSURE
THE PROTECTION OF PHARMACOLOGIC
BECAUSE- FOR EXAMPLE THE
COACHELLA VALLEY LAWMAKER
POPULATION HAS GONE FROM SIXTY
THOUSAND FARMWORKERS TO NOW
JUST OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS. CROPS MOVE OUTSIDE
OF OUR STATE LINES WE NEED TO
PROTECT THE LIVELIHOOD AND
FUTURE FARMWORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE BY SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION. CALIFORNIA THE
NATIONAL LEADER IN SETTING
STANDARDS FOR AUTOMOTIVE
EMISSIONS AND AB SEVEN TEN IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF OUR STATE
LEADING THE WAY AND PROTECTING
THE HEALTH AND WELFARE. OF
FARMWORKERS FORTY REASONS THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACARE
FOUNDATION AS PROPS TO PORT
EIGHTY SEVEN TEN AND WE THINK
MR GARCIA. BURKE LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU
MR- AND SO WITH THAT I DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE WITNESSED THAT
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. BUT THESE ARE
GARCIA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION MISTER SEA
IF YOU'RE WITH US. PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO. PROVIDED TESTIMONY. HI
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS OF A
TICKET WITH A CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION- FIGURE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR BUT WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SEVEN TEN DUE TO THE
POSSIBLE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BILL I'M
EIGHTY SEVEN CHANNEL CUT OFF
ACCESS TO THE FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES WITH DIFFERENT BILL-
GROCERY GROCERY BY AS MUCH
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT AS THEY
CAN'T WANTED TO DO THAT ONE OF
SEASON AND- PRODUCE ARE BROUGHT
IN FROM OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
SHELVES STOCKED WITH FRESH
PRODUCE- NEED HELP.
ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR
REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL MAKES
IT DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE
TO THESE COMPORTS WITH.
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS. HORN
PART FOR IMPORTED PRODUCTS TO
COMPLY WITH THE LABOR STANDARDS
WILL WILL BE TO. HELLO HAS
MINIMUM MINIMUM WAGE IN THE
COUNTRY L. DID HAVE CONTROL OF
HOW OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES
THAT THE MINIMUM WAGE. IT WILL
BE EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO TRY
TO COMPLY WITH THE STANDARD
WHEN IMPORTING FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES AS FOREIGN CURRENCIES
FLUCTUATE ON A REGULAR BASIS-
THIS BILL WILL LEAD GROCERS.
WELL THIS BILL WILL LEAD. TO
GROWTH OF MAKING A HARD
DECISION OF NOT OFFERING THAT
PRODUCT YOU TO COMPLIANCE
ISSUES. OR THE ONLY
AVAILABILITY OF THE LIST OF
PRODUCTS WILL COME FROM PAST
HARVEST THAT HAVE BEEN IN COLD
STORAGE. AND THEY WILL BE SOLD
AT MUCH HIGHER PRICES TO PEOPLE
WHO CAN AFFORD IT. FOR THESE
REASONS. CGA OPPOSES THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISSING.
FOR COMMENTS AND SO WITHOUT
BRING IT BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM. RIGHT THANK
YOU MR I'M I'M STRUGGLING WITH
WITH THIS BILL AND IT'S FOR TWO
REASONS I JUST WANT TO
ARTICULATE THAT- AND THEN- SEE
WHETHER OPEN TO. FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT MIGHT ADDRESSES
ISSUES- I'VE NOT TO GET TOO
LEGALESE BUT I DO THINK THERE'S
A COMMERCE CLAUSE PROBLEM- I'M
NOT SURE HOW THAT CHALLENGING
COURT WOULD COME OUT BUT I'M
PRETTY SURE IT WOULD BE
CHALLENGED- AND THERE'S
POTENTIALLY AN- CHALLENGE UNDER
THE- TREATY OF FORTY ALSO IN
THE CONSTITUTION BECAUSE WE
HAVE. TRADE AGREEMENTS WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES IN PARTICULAR
MEXICO- AND THIS THAT BECAUSE
OF THE- THE MINIMUM WAGE ASPECT
IN THE LABOR LAW ASPECT OF THIS
BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN NOW WOULD
ALMOST CERTAINLY PROHIBIT ANY
IMPORTATION OF ANYTHING FROM
FROM. MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA SO-
MY SUGGESTION IS- OF MY THOUGHT
AND WHEN I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT IT IS IF THIS
WERE NARROWED TO THE PESTICIDE
PIECE WHICH IS CLEARLY A HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUE. AND THE CHILD
LABOR PEACE WHICH OTHERS
UNIFORM AGREEMENT THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES OTHER
COUNTRIES. CHILD LABOR'S
INAPPROPRIATE SO- AND NOT AND
NOT THE LABOR. PEACE I THINK
YOU'D HAVE A CLEAN SALE BILL
THROUGH. THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGES- IS WRITTEN NOW THE
IT'S SORT OF IMPOSSIBLE TO
COMPLY WITH THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA'S EYES FROM WHICH- I
THINK IN THE COUNTRY. IN TERMS
STATES AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
ADJUST FOR CURRENCY RATES WE
CAN ALWAYS ALMOST COULD BE
HIGHER THAN ALL OF SOUTH
AMERICA SO- WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE CONSTITUTIONAL
THING AND I'M NOT ASKING FOR
LIKE A LEGAL OPINION BUT
WHETHER THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN THOUGHT THROUGH ADDRESSED
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DID
RAISE THAT ISSUE DID NICE JOB
OF. KIND OF GOING THROUGH IT-
AND THEN ARE YOU OPEN TO
POTENTIALLY NARROWING THE BILL
AT SOME POINT TO DO THE
PESTICIDE AND CHILD LABOR
PEACE. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THE FIRST AS WE DO
HAVE A LEGAL. RIGHT COMING
FROM- LET'S COUNCIL THE BILL
HAS VERY SPECIFICALLY- BEEN
FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY RIGHT. AND NOT THE
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH
INTERSECT WITH THE COMMERCE
CLAUSE CONCERNS THAT YOU RAISE-
THE NARROWING OF THE BILL IS
THE ACTUAL PRODUCTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SELECTED. AND THEIR
AVAILABILITY YEAR ROUND TO TRY
NOT TO GET INTO- THE ISSUES
THAT THE GROCERS ASSOCIATION
DRESSED ADDRESSED. DE UM ISSUE
OF THE LABOR WE'RE CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THAT BUT YOU KNOW THOSE
ARE VERY FUNDAMENTAL. ISSUES
THAT WE'VE ADOPTED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS STANDARDS RIGHT-
HUMAN RIGHTS STANDARDS- LIVING
LIVING WAGE FOR WORKERS. IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE ISSUE OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND SO THOSE
TWO COMPONENTS. ARE CRITICAL-
TO HOW WE DO BUSINESS CAL. AND
HOW WE SHOULD EXPECT PEOPLE
DOING BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA-
TO OPERATE IN SO I'M I'M OPEN
TO LOOKING AT IT IN. THE
INTEREST OF AVOIDING ANY LEGAL
CHALLENGES BUT LOOK WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WITH PROP TWO. AND
PROP TWELVE THAT PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT- FOCUSED
ON THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF.
CHICKENS AND OTHER ANIMALS WE
THINK THAT THERE'S PRECEDENT.
AROUND THE ISSUE OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY. THAT APPLIES. TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL THAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY. SHORT ANSWER
OPEN TO THE IDEA ON THE LABOR.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT- BOTH THE
HAVE THE SAFETY IN THE LABOR
ARE TWO PRINCIPLES THAT WE
SHOULD LIVE BY STAND BY. AND
APPLY THEM ACCORDINGLY- WHEN
WE'RE EXPECTING OTHER PRODUCE
TO BE SOLD- TO CALIFORNIANS AND
REALLY- THAT'S REALLY THE FOCUS
OF THE BILL BUT VERY OPEN- TO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS MOVING
FORWARD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN-
YES THANK YOU AND I HAD OF SOME
OF THE SAME CONCERNS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM BUT
I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE BECAUSE FOR
YEARS WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM
OUR FARMERS THAT- THAT THE
VALUES WE HOLD HERE AS
CALIFORNIANS AS FAR AS A LABOR
ISSUES AND ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
ARE MAKING THE PRODUCE IN
CALIFORNIA MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
AND SO- THIS SORT OF WOULD
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD IF
THERE'S SOME WAY TO. GET IT
THROUGH LEGALLY SO I DO LIKE OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
AS FAR AS A HIGH- MENTIONED SO
COULD YOU GO OVER AGAIN HOW YOU
PICKED THESE PRODUCTS BECAUSE
CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE SOME OF
THE PRODUCTS ARE FAIRLY
SEASONAL- I KNOW THAT- FOR
INSTANCE IN VENTURA COUNTY THAT
THAT BLUEBERRIES ARE GROWN OVER
A VERY. SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
SO- HOW WOULD WE MAKE SURE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE NOT OF BLOCKING
ACCESS TO- FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES CERTAIN TIMES OF THE
YEAR SO WE REACHED OUT TO THE
WIDE ARRAY OF AG ASSOCIATIONS
INCLUDING THE FARM PAYROLLS THE
AG COUNCILS AND THEN WE GOT
VERY SPECIFIC TO THE ACTUAL-
PRODUCERS OF THE SPECIFIC-
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES. AND
THERE WERE SOME INTERESTING
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
GROUPS WHERE THE ACTUAL FARMERS
WANTED TO BE INCLUDED BUT THE
ASSOCIATION'S. DIDN'T SEE THE-
POLITICAL INTERESTS GIVEN THE
WIDE ARRAY OF FARMERS AT THE
REPRESENT OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
AS WELL. AND SO THERE WERE SOME
CONFLICTS BETWEEN THERE AND
I'LL GIVE YOU THE EXAMPLE- THE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT WERE
PICKED. WE'VE BEEN GUARANTEED
THAT THEY ARE MADE AVAILABLE-
AND GROWN IN SPECIFIC PARTS OF
THE STATE. ALL YEAR ROUND AND
THERE ARE REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT CAN DO THAT RIGHT- THE
EXAMPLE WAS. A LOT OF PRODUCE.
IS GROWN YEAR ROUND AND- WE HAD
SOME CONVERSATIONS WITH FOLKS
FOR EXAMPLE THE BLUEBERRIES
THAT WERE ADDED LATER. BY
REQUEST OF THE INDUSTRY. AFTER
DISCUSSING WITH ALL OF THEIR
PRODUCERS THAT IT'S VERY
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE THESE YEAR
ROUND FROM CALIFORNIA. AND SO
WE PUT OUT A CALL TO ALL OF THE
ASSOCIATION'S. WITH THE HELP OF
ORGANIZATIONS KIND OF THE CALL
THE UMBRELLA ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
FARM BUREAU WESTERN GROWERS AND
OTHERS WHO LED US TO THESE-
ASSOCIATIONS THAT REPRESENT THE
SPECIFIC FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
AND THAT'S HOW WE CAME UP WITH
THE LISTEN. WE BELIEVE THAT IT
IS A MODEST. LIST OF- PRODUCED
VEGETABLES AND FRUITS THAT WE
CAN COMPLY WITH AT THAT OUR
SHELVES WILL NOT BE LEFT EMPTY-
WELL WITH OUT THOSE PRODUCTS
BECAUSE THE FARMERS THEMSELVES
HAS SAID TO US. THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO MEET THOSE EXPECTATIONS
AND PLAN FOR AND PLAN FOR A
DEMAND IF NEEDED- TO STOCK UP.
SO I SPECIFICALLY ALSO I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT- THAT THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THIS
AREA SPECIFICALLY- I SEE
LONDON'S ON THE LIST BUT I
DON'T SEE A CITRUS MUTUAL ON
THE SUPPORT LIST I ASSUME THAT
THEY REPRESENT MANY. OF
MULTINATIONAL ENTITIES TO AND
THAT THAT THAT WAS THE CONFLICT
BUT FARTHER. IN GENERAL THE
LEMON GROWERS WANTED TO BE.
THEN COLLUDED THE LEMON GROWERS
IN COACHELLA VALLEY PERIL
VALLEY. OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE MOST DEFINITELY. WANT TO
BE INCLUDED. THE ASSOCIATION'S
I BELIEVE. AND THEY CAN SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES I BELIEVE ARE
CONFLICTED. WITH THE OTHER.
PRODUCING INTEREST OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA SO LOOK FOR ME RIGHT
I REPRESENT CALIFORNIA- OUR
PRIORITY IS CALIFORNIANS AND
THE PROTECTION OF CONSUMERS-
THEIR HEALTH AND WELL BEING AND
WE'RE ALSO WANTING TO MAKE SURE
THAT- AS WE ADOPT THESE RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT THEY'RE
APPLICABLES- IN HOLDING THAT
SAME STANDARD. FOR GOODS THAT
COME INTO CALIFORNIAN ARE SOLD
OKAY AND THEN ONE MORE
QUESTION- AS FAR AS- WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WHICH OF THE
FARMWORKER WAGES WE DO HAVE
OBVIOUSLY MINIMUM WAGE BUT WE
HAVE- PEACE RIGHT ALSO SO OUR
ART IS. THAT WHAT TYPE OF- WAGE
TO OTHER STATES HAVE TO ADOPT.
TO BE ABLE TO IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA. WHAT WHAT WE HAVE
IN THE BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
PRESENTED IS THE MINIMUM WAGE.
THAT THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON RIGHT IS AT MEETING
THAT- STANDARD ACROSS THE BOARD
THAT WE BELIEVE AGAIN IS JUST
ONE COMPONENT- TO HIGHLIGHT THE
MOST IMPORTANT ONE IS THE
HALTH AND SAFETY. OF THE GOODS
THAT ARE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY OTHER ARMS COMES QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AGUIAR-CURRY-
YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER I LIKE
THAT THE IDEA OF THIS BILL YOU
KNOW THAT BUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION. WHO IMPLEMENTS THIS
BILL WHO WILL BE OUT WHAT
DEPARTMENT WILL BE IN CHARGE OF
IMPLEMENTING IT- AND- FOR
STARTERS IMAGES OF THEMSELVES
SO WE SEE. SIMILARITIES TO PROP
TWELVE IT WAS A PASSED BY
VOTERS 62% IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN D. DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AG AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. ARE TWO OF THE
AGENCIES THAT OVERSEE THOSE
ACTIVITIES I BELIEVE- THAT THAT
IS THE SAME- ENTITIES THAT WILL
OVERSEE THIS AS WELL HOW THE
AGREED TO THAT YET- I CAN'T
TELL YOU THAT THEY HAVE- BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I WILL
GET BACK TO YOU- AT THIS MOMENT
WE'VE NOT GOTTEN ANY
SIGNIFICANT PUSHBACK. RIGHT
BUT- MAIN FOCUS OF THE BILL HAS
BEEN ON THE ISSUE OF ADDRESSING
LIKE THE FIRST QUESTION THAT
WAS ASKED REGARDING THE
COMMERCE CLAUSE- IN AGAIN I
DON'T HAVE THE WHOLE LIST OF
PRODUCTS IN FRONT OF ME- BUT I
DO APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUINS QUESTIONS TO YOU-
REGARDING PARTICULAR BLOOD
BLUEBERRIES THERE CERTAIN
PLACES. YOU CAN GROWN THEY DO
WELL. A THERE ARE TWO THAT WE
DO TO PER. OUR PRODUCE. I'LL
SLIDE OF THE UNITED STATES- AND
THEIR CONTRACTS THE FARMERS
HAVE TO GO THROUGH AS WELL- AND
I'M SURE THOSE CONTRACTS AND
RETAIL INDUSTRY SOME JUST. ARE
YOU KNOW I'M I'M GONNA- GOING
TO TODAY ON THIS BILL THAT JUST
PASSED THE HOUSE OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS I THINK YOU AND I CAN
WORK ON THOSE. THANK YOU IF YOU
LIKE I'LL REPEAT THE LIST AGAIN
RIGHT. THANK YOU OF FRESH
APPLES ASPARAGUS BELL PEPPERS
BLUEBERRIES DATES. I KNOW YOU
MELONS LEMONS NECTARINES OLIVES
AND TABLE GRAPES AND THEY WERE
AGAIN THE OTHER. PRODUCES THAT
WANTED TO JOIN BUT THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS- SINCE MICHIGAN.
WE'RE CONFLICTED. WITH THE
INTERESTS THAT THEY REPRESENT
THAT MANY TIMES ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE. FOR US THE REAL
QUESTION IS A- WHOSE FIRST. WHO
DO WE PRIORITIZE FIRST AND WHY
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY AT
THE CORE OF- THE QUESTION- FOR
YOU ALL TO DECIDE. WHEN
DETERMINING THE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU- SOME OF OUR
FLOOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I AM IN
THE SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY WE
TALKED ABOUT IT IT IS AN
INTERESTING. CONCEPT BECAUSE
WE'VE HEARD IT A FEW TIMES.
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUILDING. THE REGULATIONS AND
THE BURDEN THAT WE PUT ON.
CALIFORNIA AG AND REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE IMPOSE ON THEM. ARE
TREMENDOUS- THERE IS A COST TO
DOING BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT SOMETIMES- IN
MY OPINION IS REALLY REALLY
EGREGIOUS AND QUITE FRANKLY
AGGRESSIVE. WE HAVE NOT ALWAYS
BEEN. KIND AS A BODY- TO THE AG
COMMUNITY HAS RELATE TO SOME OF
THE LAWS THAT WE DO PASS. SO I
AM INCREDIBLY ENCOURAGED THAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
CALIFORNIA FARMERS NOW. AND
I'VE SPOKEN TO SOME OF OUR
LARGER PRODUCERS IN. THERE
ISN'T AN IDEA THAT WE COULD
HELP PRODUCT SHORTAGES AT
CERTAIN TIMES OF THE YEAR AND
THEY THEY BRING INTO THE IMPORT
OF PRODUCTS- IN FROM MEXICO. A
LOT OF THE LARGER ONES. ALREADY
THE FALL UNDER THE SAME
GUIDELINES I MEAN THEY THEY
THEY MEET THE STANDARDS FROM
CALIFORNIA TO BRING THOSE
PRODUCTS AND SO. I GUESS WE
COUPLE QUESTIONS. AT WHAT POINT
DOWN THE LINE DO WE CONFIRM
THAT AND IS THERE ANY LIABILITY
ON THE DISC- LIKE TO
DISTRIBUTORS BECAUSE A LOT OF
PRODUCE GOES THROUGH THIS NEW.
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS- BEFORE IT
GETS TO THE STORE. SO WE
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT. AND THEN
ALSO THERE'S A TERMINATE HER
TODAY FOR THE FIRST TIME- COLD
KENNY SECTORS WHICH ARE SOME OF
THE SMALL PRODUCERS. THAT MAY
BE AN ETHNIC STORE. A MOM AND
POP GROCERY STORE MIGHT BUY
FROM A LOCAL GROWER THAT'S VERY
LOCALIZED- MAYBE IT'S A FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESS. WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO THEM WILL THAT LITTLE
MOM AND POP BE LIABLE AT THAT
POINT- BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE DOCUMENTATION MAYBE IT'S
JUST LIKE SAID A FAMILY OWNED
SMALL OPERATION. SO I
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS-
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A HUGE
STEP FORWARD IN PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA ACT. I DO THINK
THERE'S A FEW THINGS WE DO NEED
TO FLUSH OUT AND SO ONE IS THAT%
THE LIABILITY ON THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. OR THE
ART ON THE RETAILERS AND THEN
ON THE MOM AND POP SOME OF THE
SMALLER PRODUCERS- I DON'T WANT
TO SEE. A STATE AGENCY.
IMPOSING FINES AND FEES ON OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ON BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS- I
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU POLLS- WILL
GOING TO HAVE TO WORK ON THAT-
AND GET BACK TO YOU AND SEE HOW
WE- AT SOME PROTECTIONS- TO
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERNS. RIGHT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT- I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT PROTECTING
THE ENVIRONMENT IS A GOOD
THING- HAVING LIVING WAGES FOR
YOU KNOW OUR WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA IS A GOOD THING. AND
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF OUR CONSUMERS IS A GOOD
THING. AND MANY OF US HERE WILL
WILL ARGUE THAT THAT'S WHY WE
PASSED. THE POLICIES THAT WE DO.
ON THE FLIP SIDE IS THAT- WE
DON'T IMPOSE ALL SAYING. YOU
KNOW EXPECTATIONS ON. BUSINESS
ERA OCCURRING IN CALIFORNIA IN
THIS CASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE FRESH FOODS. AND GOODS THAT
ARE SOLD HERE. AND IN THE
INTEREST OF PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS- WE
BELIEVE THAT BY DOING THIS. OUT
WE RAISE THE BAR ALL THE WAY
ACROSS THE BOARD AND WE
CONTINUE. TO SEE A ROBUST
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR ME I SEE THE
DIRECT CONNECTION TO THE WORK
THAT I DO IN THE ENVIRONMENT
SPACE. AND I AND I SEE THE
DIRECT CONNECTION THAT HAS TO
THE CONSTITUENTS THAT. I AND
MANY OF YOU SERVE. IN AG
COMMUNITIES ARE ARE FARMWORKERS
BY. US SO- I APPRECIATE THAT
THE QUESTIONS WE WILL LOOK AT
THAT- AND MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
GET SOME. OF PROTECTIONS ARE
RESPONSES TO THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU RAISE BUT JUST WANTED TO
REINFORCE THE POINT. ABOUT WHY
THIS IS IMPORTANT. TO US NO AND
I CAN CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE ENCOURAGE
ALL OF US LIKE. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND I SAID ON LABOR
COMMITTEES WELL. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF BILLS THAT. COULD SEEM
VERY GOOD THERE IS A COST TO
THAT. SO HAS REMOVING THIS
THING FOR MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT
THIS LIKE THIS IS GOING TO BE.
A COST INCREASE TO THE
CONSUMER. I CANNOT STE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT. TO DO
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA THERE IS
AN EXPENSE TO THAT THAT IS
GOING TO BE PASSED ON THE LINE
I THINK WE AS A BODY. NEED TO
KEEP THAT IN MIND TOO THAT WE
THERE'S A BALANCED ALL OF THIS.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. I SHOULD MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
SHE. I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. ON
ON THE- YOU YOU NEVER SHOW AWAY
FROM. THREADING THE TOUGH
NEEDLES- I DO SURE A LOT OF THE
SAME CONCERNS OVER FOR TODAY ON
THE LEGAL SIDE ON THE CONCERNS
FOR THE INTERSTATE COMMERCE
PIECE- BUT I HAVE TO AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES. ON ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE ON THIS THAT.
AGRICULTURAL AND CALIFORNIA IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. IN THE
COMMENTS FROM MR FLORA THAT WE
PUT EXTRA STRENUOUS REGULATIONS.
ON OUR INDUSTRY HERE. IT ISN'T
JUST AGRICULTURISTS INCLUDES
OIL IT'S EVERYTHING ACROSS THE
BOARD THERE IS A HIGHER COST OF
DOING BUSINESS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK MR
GARCIA AS YOU'VE MENTIONED NO
WE SEE A LOT OF OR NORMAL
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION ALLIES.
NOT SHOWING SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT AS SAID THAT
THEIR BODIES ARE MADE UP OF
GROWERS IN MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
STATES AND COUNTRIES. AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE LOOKED
AT BEING VICE CHAIRMAN OF THIS
COMMITTEE GOSH GOING OF WHAT
WE'RE ON SIX SEVEN YEARS NOW.
IS THE VERY SIMPLE THING OF
WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GROWERS. NOT FOR THE
ASSOCIATION. NOT NOW FOR. THE
BIGGER SUFFERED FOR THE MOM AND
POP SMALL GROWERS IS TRYING TO
KEEP THE FAMILY FARM ALIVE.
DOES THIS HELP THEM. DOES THAT
HELP THEM COMPETE ON A LARGER
SCALE. WHERE DOES IT HURT THAT.
AND I BELIEVE THE INTENT ON
THIS LEGISLATION HERE BEFORE US
TODAY IS TO CREATE AS MUCH
IRWIN SAID. A MORE EQUAL
PLAYING FIELD FOR OUR SMALLER
FAMILY GROWERS- ON TO ADD THAT
VALUE OF THE HARD WORK THAT
THEY GO THROUGH- I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU MISTER
GARCIA ON ADDRESSING SOME OF
THESE OTHER CONCERNS I'M I'M
SURE. YOU'LL BE HEARING FROM MR
FLOOR MORE ON ON THE LABOR SIDE
AND MISTER CUNNINGHAM ON THE
LEGAL EAST SIDE- I WILL SUPPORT
YOU TODAY ON THIS BUT I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THIS TIED UP
AS IT MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU
HE WAS VERY SHARE ANY OTHER.
SOME COMES FROM I WAS THE
COMMITTEE. SOME OF THE UP WITH-
MISTER GARCIA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FOR I MEAN I ECHO
WHAT A LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES HAD
JUST MENTIONED. IN MY DISTRICT-
WE WERE KNOWN FOR SPARES WE HAD
THE BIGGEST DISPARITIES
FESTIVAL. AND STATE OF
CALIORNIA I MEAN. THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WOULD COME THROUGH BUT
NOT JUST FOR THE PURPOSE FOR
THE FOR THE EVENT BUT- OUR
FARMER OWNERS- FARM GROWERS-
THE BEST BURGERS. I'M TALKING
STICK AS A STRINGER. YOU KNOW
NOT NOT NOT TO SAY ANYTHING
WHAT MEXICO BRINGS IN BECAUSE
THEY'RE VERY VERY SKINNY RIGHT-
BUT IT WAS THE BEST AND IT WAS
AND WE FOLLOW EVERY REGULATION
THAT THE STATE PUTS OUR FARMERS
TO I MEAN WE LEAD WERE THE BEST
RIGHT. BATES WHEN WE WHEN WE
SAY THAT IT COMES AT THE COST
AND I UP AND I'M GLAD THAT-
MISS IRWIN PRODUCT THAT
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BREAK BRING
YOU KNOW UP AND EVEN PLAYING
FIELD HOPEFULLY THIS WOULD EVEN
BRING SOME OF OUR FARMERS TO
REGROW WHAT THEY DID BEFORE
BECAUSE OUR FARMERS. THEY'LL
SWITCH. WITH WHAT IS WHAT IS
WHAT WHAT. WHAT ILLEGAL BUT NOT
EQUALS OUT BUT- WHAT THEY CAN
PRODUCE WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
PENCILS OUT WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY. YOU KNOW AND IT IS NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE FARM WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY LOVE THEIR
FARMWORKERS YOU KNOW THEY THEY
ARE. AND SO I'M GLAD YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD- I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND I AM I AM I'M
HOPING THAT THAT OPENS UP SO
THAT WE CAN EVENTUALLY BRING
BACK- YOU KNOW MORE HERE. AND
FILL UP OUR OUR SHELVES IF THEY
SAY THAT THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
FILL THOSE OUT WE ARE WE WILL
FARMERS WILL FILL UP THE
SHELVES THREE. THANK YOU SIR
THANK THANK YOU SENATE MEMBER
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY THIS TIME WE
WILL OPEN IT UP- OR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM WISHING TO. PROVIDE
SOME COMMENTS ALL THE TIME TO
DO SO SEEN OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE
ANY COLORS IN THE QUEUE. TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT THE COMMENTS.
WE DO- CAN TO- REGISTER PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO FOR YOUR LINE NUMBER.
WILL GO FIRST TO LINE FIFTY
THREE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS OPERATOR MEDINA CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVEN PENN. OF THE WATER
THE ID DELIVERS A PROXIMITY 97%
IS USED FOR AGRICULTURAL
PURPOSES. MAKING IT POSSIBLE
FOR IMPERIAL COUNTIES RANKING
AS ONE OF THE TOP TEN AFTER
CULTURAL REGIONS NATIONWIDE. BY
INCREASING APPLICABILITY OF THE
SAME COMPANY STANDARDS WE CAN
OFTEN CREATE THAT HEARING THE
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK. YOUR SUPPORT
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT
COLORADO. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE. GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS RYAN ELENA BE HAPPY
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND JUST WOULD LIKE
TO OUR ALAINA COMMENTS WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WE'LL
MORNING MEDICARE MEMBERS THIS
IS CHRIS KAHN REPRESENTING THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
AND SPORT THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE. FIFTY THREE- ME
LIVE FIFTY THREE YOU SEEM TO
HAVE DROPPED OUT A IF YOU DO
NEED TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY FOUR. YES GOOD
MORNING THIS IS- GEORGE HERE TO
RANCHO A GREAT DAY AND I'M
GOING TO COACHELLA VALLEY AND I
AM HERE IN SUPPORT. STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TEN THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ADAM
BORCHARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE INTENT OF AB
SEVEN TEN THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY ONE. YES TO
NO PARTY WITH GROWING COACHELLA
VALLEY AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT
AT. EIGHTY SEVEN TEN. NINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN I COMMITTEE-
CHAMPS KIRK WITH SOME LIGHT AND
PRETTY LADY VINEYARDS IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN TEN. WE'LL
GO NEXT TO LINE TWENTY TWO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. LINE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO YOU CAN BE
HEARD GO AHEAD PLEASE OKAY MY
NAME IS- GOOD MORNING THE
GERMAN REALISM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ON THIS
CURLING IN MYSELF AND MY WIFE
MARIA CARMEN LOWER LOWER KEYS
WE ARE MINORITY OR THE ORGANIC
AVOCADO FARMERS IN TEMECULA
CALIFORNIA- I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TEN AND I
WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT. UNDER
THE CURRENT UNDER OUR CURRENT
LOWS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS ARE JUST TAKING A
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE POSITION WE
HAVE REGISTERED YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
THE CALL. OKAY THANK YOU. LINE
FIFTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MARKET SHARE A CO RICHET
CALIFORNIA WOMEN FOR
AGRICULTURE AND CONSUMER
STRONGLY SUPPORT SEVEN CAN.
NINE SEVEN. HELLO YOUR OPEN GO
AHEAD PLACE. HELLO YEAH HEAR ME
CAN OKAY I'M NOT HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LAURIE MAY SHINE MY FAMILY
PRODUCES AVOCADOS THE
CARPINTERIA CALIFORNIA. SMALL
FAMILY AVOCADO FARMER A WOMAN
IN THE CALIFORNIA DECEMBER I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT AT
87% THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EMITTED HERE THERE'S NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU DROPPING HER OUT WITH
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
JULY CLOSE YES LOOK I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INTELLIGENCE
ON THIS MATTER. IT IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE- AND
WE HEAR IT- ALL THE TIME WHEN
IT COMES TO CALIFORNIA AG.
PRODUCERS THE NEED FOR US TO
PRIORITIZE- THE INDUSTRY FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF A FOOD CHAIN
SUPPLY- FROM THE IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THE THOUSANDS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
IN CALIFORNIA AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY- SETTING THE BAR
FOR OTHERS BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY.
PROVISIONS THAT- WE ADOPT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS. AND SOUL I JUST
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT
ONCE AGAIN I WANNA I ALSO THINK
THE- OF GROWERS WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR CLOSE
TO A YEAR. OUT WITH OUR OFFICE.
AND AND JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT-
THIS HAS BEEN- A WORK IN
PROGRESS AS WE SEE OTHER
CHALLENGES COME BEFORE THE
INDUSTRY- AND- THE NEED TO
PROTECT- THOSE WHO WORK IN IT.
AND THOSE WHO CONSUME THESE
PRODUCE SO- FIND BALANCE. OF
POLICY BUT A IMPORTANT ONE THAT
I HAVE PRIORITIZED AND THAT I
HOPE THAT MANY OF YOU WILL IN
THIS I COMMITTEE- AS WELL AND I
INVITE. YOU TO JOIN ME IN THIS
EFFORT AS CO AUTHORS PRINCIPLE
OUT THERE'S A TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THIS BILL- COME TO REALITY
SO WITH THAT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL APPRECIATE
WORK AND I'VE NO DOUBT THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK TO-
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AT THIS
HEARING. AND LOOK I AGREE WITH
A LOT OF COMMENTS HAVE BEEN AS
A STATE THIS LEGISLATURE WE'VE
MADE SOME SOME DEEP INVESTMENTS
WHEN IT COMES TO INSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE THAT WE
PRODUCE THE VERY BEST PRODUCE
IN THE WORLD- AND YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY. WE HAVE DONE THAT IN
MANY WAYS AND FOR MANY REASONS
YOU KNOW FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF A FARM AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS FOR YOU KNOW
ENVIRONMENTAL- REASONS. ABOUT
THE ONE THING I HEARD WHEN I
WAS ON THE ONE CONSISTENT THING
I HEARD IN ALL OF THE STOPS WE
HAD IN OUR AGRICULTURAL TOUR
THIS FALL. WAS THE NEED TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO ENSURE THAT. OUR
AGRICULTURE- THAT WE LEVEL THIS
PLAYING FIELD BECAUSE THEY FEEL
THAT THEY FACE A COMPETITIVE- A
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE A LOT OF
THESE EFFORTS TO BECOME. THE
YOU KNOW- DO YOU TO HAVE THE
BEST- PRODUCE IT'S COME AT A
COST THIS IS BEEN MENTIONED AND
SYSTEM APPRECIATE THIS EFFORT-
AND SO WITH THAT I KNOW WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. BY VICE CHAIR
MATHIS SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE UP WITH- A MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ONE ITEM FOR AB
SEVEN TEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA. A MOTION AS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS. RIVAS AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT VOTING FLORA.
LARA I AGREE- ONE SURE WHEN I
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE IDEA TO ROCK GUY
TO BE APPROVED WHILE I WOULD.
WOOD I. HAS NUMBER NINE VOTE
THANK YOU YEAH- WITH APPLE FILE
ITEM. SEVEN NUMBER ONE- OF THE
BILL- RELATED TO BILLS. SENATE
BILL FIVE. THE SECOND- RATHER
THAT IT BY JOHN. A CHRISTIAN.
THANK YOU CHAIR MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF- AB THREE FIFTY
COURAGEOUS A THREE YEAR PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP CREATE
CONSERVATION MANAGEMENT PLANS
FOR LANDOWNERS AND FARMERS.
THESE PLANS WILL DRESS THE
IMPACTS OF THEIR AGRICULTURAL
PROPERTIES FROM THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA. MOVING
FORWARD I AM COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO EXPRESS
THE AXIS TO THIS GRANT PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE MORE CRITICAL
OVERDRAFT BASINS BISONS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN IN THE SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS KATIE PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER FOR
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST. THANK
YOU SEVEN MEMBER- OPERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE CONNECT- IS
PATTERSON WHO- WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IT'S PAST IF YOU WITH US
PLEASE- PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME IS KATIE
PATTERSON NINE THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY MANAGER FOR AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY THREE FIFTY I'D
FIRST LIKE TO SHARE A LITTLE
ABOUT OUR ORGANIZATION FOR
THOSE WHO MAY NOT KNOW THE REST
OF OUR WORK YES HE NOW HER
FORTIETH YEAR CREATED THE
CONSERVATION AGRICULTURE
MOVEMENT WHICH SEEKS FOR THE
LAND AND FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
GROW ARCHES. AT THE MOVEMENT'S
LEADERS IN THE NATIONAL
AGRICULTURAL LAND TRUST WE HAVE
THREE PRIORITY PROTECTING
AGRICULTURAL LAND PROMOTING
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND FARMING
PRACTICES IN KEEPING FARMERS ON
THE LAND. YES TO UNITE.
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND
POLICYMAKERS AND DEVELOPING
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS LIKE EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY THAT PROTECT
FARMLAND AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO WHERE ARE WE NOW WATER
SCARCITY A CHANGING CLIMATE NEW
REGULATIONS AND A GROWING
POPULATION ARE JUST SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING FARMERS AND
FARMLAND IN CALIFORNIA. IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL REGION. AN
ANTIQUE WORK IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WE FOUND THAT HIGH
QUALITY FARMLAND MORE
PRODUCTIVE VERSATILE AND
RESILIENT WITH A RELIABLE WATER
SOURCE IS VERY LIMITED WITH
ONLY 9% OF ROUGHLY SIX MILLION
ACRES OF IRRIGATED FARMLAND IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. BEING
OF HIGH QUALITY AND
EXPERIENCING LOW WATER STRESS.
ACCORDING TO THE STATE'S STRAPS
GROUNDWATER REPORT STATE WIDE.
GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT IS
ESTIMATED TO BE IN THE RANGE OF
TWO TO TWO AND A HALF MILLION
ACRE FEET PER YEAR. AND
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
INDICATIONS ARE THAT NEARLY 40%
OF THE CURRENT SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY CROPLAND OR SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
LAND. MAY NEED TO BE FOLLOWED
OR RETIRE TO BRING GROUNDWATER
AQUIFER BALANCE. THIS SHIFT
WOULD HAVE AN ECONOMIC COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. ACCORDING TO
THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT THERE
WILL BE SUBSTANTIAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ACHIEVING
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT BUT THE LONG TERM
ECONOMIC IMPACT WOULD BE
CONSIDERABLY GREATER IF
GROUNDWATER. USE IS NOT MANAGE
TO SEE AN UGLY ANTISEPTIC
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS NOT
MADE AVAILABLE PERFECT MY
CONSERVATION PLANNING. SO WHY
EIGHTY THREE FIFTY. ACROSS THE
STATE FARMERS ARE STRUGGLING
WITH DEVELOPING ON FARM
CONSERVATION PLANS AND REACHING
THE WATER USE REDUCTION GOAL
BUT THE ACT WE RECOGNIZE IN
MANY CASES SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS MAY
REQUIRE INTENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. INCLUDING LANGUAGE
SUPPORT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS AFFECT MATH. THIS
BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE INNOVATION
AND ALTERNATIVE ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE APPROACHES TO
AGRICULTURAL LAND MANAGEMENT.
AND SEEKS TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY FOLLOWING
INCREASING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND CONSERVATION PLANNING FOR
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS IS
ESSENTIAL TO HELP THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S AMBITIOUS GOALS.
ESTABLISHED IN A SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
WHEN FARMS AND RANCHES ARE MOST
MANAGED FOR MULTIPLE BENEFITS
THEY HELP TO PROTECT THE MOST
VALUABLE AND PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL LAND. PROJECT HE
SAYS THAT THE GROUNDWATER
SUPPLIES AND SUPPORT CRITICAL
HABITAT FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST I FELT I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS MISS
PATTERSON WE DO HAVE- A WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION THE MISS AND-
DUBAY PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
COALITION. MISTER BAY IF YOU'RE
WITH US. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING SHERRY IN
MA'AM. MY NAME IS SANDY BAY AND
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
COALITION AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. TODAY ON EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY. THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION IS AN
ORGANIZATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
ENTITIES LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND IT CONSISTS OF
EXPERTS WITH TECHNICAL LEGAL
AND PROFESSIONAL GROUNDWATER
EXPERTISE. OUR MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN SUSTAINABLY MANAGING
GROUNDWATER SINCE LONG BEFORE
THE PASSAGE OF CIGNA WHICH WE
SUPPORTED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
C. G. C. HAD AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY- WE WERE SEEKING
AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND THE GRANT
PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND ALL
GROUNDWATER BASINS NOT JUST
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SPONSORS
FOR WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS. THERE ARE
CONVERSATIONS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAS COMMITTED TO EXPAND
THE APPLICABILITY OF AB THREE
FIFTY TO INCLUDE CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASIS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. REMOVING THE
RESTRICTION THAT ONLY
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ARE
ELIGIBLE. CDC IS A OF THE
EFFORTS TO HELP LANDOWNERS
REACH WATER USE REDUCTION GOALS
ARE REQUIRED FOR A GROUNDWATER
BASIN TO BE SUSTAINABLY MANAGED
UNDERSTATEMENT. AND THEREFORE
BASED ON THE COMMITMENT TO
EXPAND THE BILL TO CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BASIN STATEWIDE
CDC'S POSITION WILL CHANGE TO
SUPPORT ITS AMENDED. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR ON AB THREE FIFTY AND
THE VAST FUNDING NEEDS THAT
EXIST FOR GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME MISTER BAY
WILL BE SURE YOUR COMMENTS WITH
THAT. I'LL BE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. THE C. NINE- BUT I
HOPE SO I. CUNNINGHAM YEAH I
JUST WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS WILLINGNESS TO
POTENTIALLY EXPAND THE BILL
IT'S ALL CRITICALLY. OVER
DRAFTED BASINS WHICH WILL HELP
AND PASS ROBLES LOSS OF SERVICE
AND OTHER AREAS- THEY'RE HAVING
HAVING SIMILAR ISSUES COUPLE
DEALING WITH CIGNA CORRECT AND-
THAT ARE NOT REALLY THEIR FAULT
BUT A FUNCTION OF. CHANGING
CLIMATE DROUGHT AND SO FORTH SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
CLOSELY. WORKING WITH THE STATE
OR STATE. OKAY ANY- THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS C. NINE
OPENED UP FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FOR COMMENT I KNOW WHEN
THIS ROOM WILLING TO. PROVIDE
SOME COMMENTS AS TIME TO DO SO
C. NOT- OPENED UP. TWO PHONE
LINES- MISTER OPERATOR ARE
THERE ANY COLORS IN THE QUEUE
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS ON THIS
LEGISLATION. AND AFTER ANY
COMMENTS ON THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER THIS IS MARK
FENSTER BAKER AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT CAN SUPPORT. FIVE
FIFTY THREE. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN.
NINE THIRTY ONE. THE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN BE ABLE TO GO
AHEAD PLEASE I YEAH I DIDN'T
GIVE ME THE NUMBER- DAVE
BRUNSON COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH
FAMILY FARMERS IN SUPPORT. NINE
FORTY NINE. GOOD ALMOST
AFTERNOON MEMBERS FLY BACK ON
MARKETS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT
OF. EIGHTY THREE FIFTY. LINE
THIRTY SIX. FIVE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. THIS BEGAN YES BUT-
YES I DIDN'T KNOW OUR CURRENT-
FOR CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED
ORGANIC FARMERS IN SUPPORT.
EACH YEAR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
INTO IT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MISTER OPERATOR OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VIA- I WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ATTENTION
WE HAVE A MOTION LIKE VICE
CHAIR MATHIS A SECOND BY SOME
MEMBER JONES SAWYER MADAM
SECRETARY OF COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON ITEMS. AB THREE
FIFTY- VEHICLE GO OFF- MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA
FLORA I AGREE- ONE. IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE IDEA PUT ROCK I
BE APPROVED WHILE I WOULD.
WOULD I ATTEND ZERO DOESN'T
BILLS AT A MOVING ON TO SECOND
BILL THE DAY US FILE ITEM EIGHT
SENATE BILL THREE NINE ONE-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB. THREE NINETY ONE HELPS TO
BILL ON AND AMP THE TO OUR
PULMONARY HABITAT AND FORCED
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURAL AB THIRTY
ONE WILL HELP US TO MEET THE
STATE AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT AIMS TO
CONSERVE 30% OF THE HABITAT FOR
BIODIVERSITY BY TWENTY THIRTY.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS
ELAINE TREVINO PRESIDENT OF THE
ALMOND ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU VERY MUCH I'M YOUR
MODERATOR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS ELAINE TREVINO AGAIN
REPRESENTING THE ON ALLIANCE.
CALIFORNIA ALMOND FARMERS KNOW
EVERY ALLMAN EXIT BECAUSE THE
HONEY BEE VISIT ALMOND BLOSSOM
WITHOUT HONEYBEES THERE DO YOU
ALLMAN- AN ORCHARD BEACH ARE
THANKFUL TO CARRY POLLEN FROM
ONE VARIETY ACROSS THE TREE
ROAD TO ANOTHER RIGHT. ALLMAN
POLLEN PROVIDES ABUNDANT HIGH
QUALITY NUTRITION TO BE. I NEED
THE HIGH COME OUT OF ALMOND
ORCHARDS STRONGER THAN WHEN
THEY ARRIVED GETTING BEATEN
BEEKEEPERS A STRONG STAR EACH
YEAR. SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT GROWING FLOWERING COVER
CROPS BETWEEN THE TREE ROAD IS
ENHANCE THE D. HELP EVEN
FURTHER PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL
FORAGE BEFORE AND AFTER THE
ALMOND BLOOM. AND I GAVE BIRTH
DIED FOR B. R. INDUSTRY
UNDERSTAND THAT HONEY BEES AND
OTHER POLLINATORS NEED EVER
VARIED AND NUTRITIOUS DIET AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THREE NINE
ONE WHICH BRINGS TOGETHER
AGRICULTURE CONSERVATION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY TO
INCREASE HABITAT FOR
POLLINATORS AND WORKING LAND.
EIGHTY THREE NINE ONE WILL HELP
FOSTER ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND
LEVERAGE EXISTING INVESTMENT IN
POLLINATOR HEALTH AND HELP
GROUNDWORK IMPLEMENT THOSE
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION
PRACTICES. THAT BENEFIT HONEY
BEES AS THEY FORAGE FOR POLLEN
AND NECTAR IN THE ORCHARD.
EIGHTY THREE NINE ONE WILL HELP
GROWERS IMPLEMENTED IMPORTANT
CONSERVATION PRACTICES THAT
BENEFIT HONEY BEES AS THEY
FORAGED- AGAIN AND AFTER POLLEN
AND NECTAR THE ORCHARD WORKING
LANDS OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND HABITAT AND FORAGE FOR
POLLINATORS. WHICH HELP THE
CLUSTER CARBON AND CONTINUES.
TO CLIMB AT RISK REDUCTION.
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMB RISK RIGHT
IN THE FURTHER ENGAGED AND
DELIVERING SOLUTIONS THAT
BENEFIT POLLINATORS EIGHT
INVESTMENT IS CRITICAL FOR
ACTIVITIES AND ACCELERATE THE
ADOPTION OF CONSERVATION
PRACTICES THAT INTEGRATE
POLLINATOR HABITAT. AND FORAGE
ON THESE WORKING LANDS BEYOND
ALLIANCE IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL AND SINCERELY THING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAN'T GO OUT
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. THAT ON AB
THREE NINE ONE. THANK YOU MR
VINO- THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
REGISTERED- THERE'S NO
RESTAURANT ADDITION TO THIS
BILL. BRING BACK THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEE
NON- OPENED UP FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR COMMENT ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM WILLING TO. BOB
PROVIDES INCOME IS NOT THE TIME
TO DO SO C. NONE- THIS DROP
WRITER IS THERE ANYONE- IN THE
QUEUE TO PROVIDE COMMENTS FOR
THIS BILL. WE HAVE SEVERAL
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE SIXTY FOUR.
YES HELLO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF THE GRASSLAND
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BUT REQUESTING AN
AMENDMENT- AS WE HAVE
PREVIOUSLY REACHED OUT TO THE
OFFICE OFFICE AND ASK THEM TO
CONSIDER EXPANDING THE SCOPE OF
WHERE- THESE GRANT DOLLARS IN
OPPORTUNITIES TO. COLLABORATE
ON POLLINATOR HABITAT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE AS AN EXAMPLE THE
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT IS
SQUARELY LOCATED IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
SURROUNDED BY AGRICULTURE ON
ALL SIDES AND HAD RECENTLY
RECEIVED- WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD GRANT TO PLANT POLLINATOR
HABITAT ALONG OUR CANALS. AND
IN OTHER OPEN AREAS WITHIN THE
DISTRICT- POLLINATOR HABITAT IS
IMPORTANT- AND I THINK WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING WE THINK
THE INVESTMENT SHOULD BE AS
BROAD AS POSSIBLE SO WE HOPE
THE AUTHOR WILL RECONSIDER THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROPOSED AND
THANK YOU. FOR BRINGING THIS
MATTER FORWARD SHE. NEXTERA
NEXT CALLER WE WILL. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE TWENTY ONE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS BOTH THE MATHEMATICALLY
OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA EIGHTY
KEEPERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE BOTTOM
LINE TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR KAREN NUMBER
THREE SECURING YOUR WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY THREE. A GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY RUSSIAN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
SUPPORT. NINE SIXTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY AND
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION
AND AFTER LANGUAGE TO INCLUDE-
TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE THAT
ENCOURAGE THE PLANTING OF
NATIVE PLANTS FOR THE BENEFIT
OF NATIVE BIODIVERSITY. THANK
YOU. LINE. THIRTY ONE. NINE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DAVE RANKED AND COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS WE
SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY THREE.
NINE FORTY THREE A LIGHT IS
OPEN. PLEASE PICK UP YOUR
HANDSET OR CHECK YOUR MUTE
FEATURE. WE'RE TAKING OUR CUE
LINE FORTY THREE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO RE QUEUE PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO NINE SIXTY SEVEN. THIRTY
ONE YEAH HI VALERIE NERA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MR
OPERATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH- YOU
WILL TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS INTO
CONSIDERATION AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS. AND I ASKED
SOURCE RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND TESTING THANK YOU- I
KNOW WE HAD A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY VICE CHAIR
MATT THIS IS OUR SECOND. THEY
GO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ON AB THREE NINETY ONE
VIA FOOD WATER MOTION TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS HI RIVAS AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. FOR A- LARA I
AGREE.AYE GRAY AYE IRWIN IRWIN
AYE JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
AYE LEVINE LEVINE IDEA COULD
WALK HI BE APPROVED BY I WOULD.
WOULD I HAVE ELEVEN VOTE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU. RIGHT NEXT UP WE
HAVE MISTER CHAIRMAN WHICH AB.
ONE TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR COLLEAGUES PLEASED
TO PRESENT- LEGISLATION IS ON
THE BILL ONE TWENTY FIVE IT'S A
FOOD AND FARMING RESILIENCE
BOND. HI AND I'VE INTRODUCED
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT'S TIME
THAT- WE FOCUS AND WE BUILD. A
FOUNDATION FOR A BETTER FOOD
SYSTEM HERE IN OUR STATE ONE
THAT'S MORE RESILIENT MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND MORE JUST. WHEN
I WAS- I WANTED CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE- LAST
FALL. YEAH I EMBARKED ON A
STATEWIDE TOUR MANY OF YOU
HELPED- IDENTIFY LOCATIONS AND-
ACCORDING VISITS A LOT OF YOU.
SHOULD DIGITORUM JOIN ME WHILE
WE WERE ON THIS TOUR AND WE
KNOW THAT WE HAD TO CUT SHORT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC BUT- IN IT TOO MUCH WE
VISITED OVER FIFTY SITES-
ENGAGED. OVER SEVENTY
STAKEHOLDERS- WE DID RELEASE A
REPORT RECENTLY ON ON OUR
FINDINGS AND SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT WOULD
GENERATED ON THE TOUR BUT- WHEN
WE GET STAKEHOLDERS WE MET WITH
FARMERS WITH AGRICULTURAL AND
FARM WORKERS WITH INDUSTRY
UNION LEADERS WITH
ENVIRONMENTALISTS WITH
SCIENTISTS- AND RESEARCH TEAMS
FROM UC DAVIS UCLA. NOW WITH
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS- AND
YOU KNOW ON ON ON OUR TOUR WE
VISITED A JUST- SEVERAL
OPERATIONS AG OPERATIONS
MASSIVE FARMS SMALL FARMS WE
VISITED- SOME COMMUNITY GARDENS
ARE FOOD BANKS WE KNOW PEOPLE
ACROSS OUR STATE WHO. ARE
INVESTED IN AND WORK EVERY
SINGLE DAY TO PRODUCE OUR FOOD
AND TO KEEP EVERY RESIDENT HERE
IN THIS STATE AND AROUND THE
WORLD THAT. AND THROUGHOUT OUR
TO IT WAS CLEAR THAT KOBE
NINETEEN HAS LAID BARE THE
VULNERABILITIES AND THE
INEQUITIES WITHIN OUR FOOD
SYSTEM. YOU KNOW SINCE THE
BEGINNING A PANDEMIC THE NUMBER
OF FOOD INSECURE RESIDENTS HERE
CALIFORNIA HAS INCREASED BY TWO
POINT ONE MILLION- BRINGING THE
TOTAL FOOD INSECURE PEOPLE ARE
SET UP TO SIX POINT FOUR.
MILLION RESTAURANTS AND OTHER
FOOD RELATED BUSINESSES THEY'VE
BEEN- THEY'VE BEEN HIT HARD. BY
THIS PANDEMIC MANY OF CLOSE
THEIR DOORS AND WON'T REOPEN.
SO FARMERS HAVE HAVE HAVE HAVE
GONE THROUGH HUGE VOLATILITY-
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT RELY ON
RESTAURANT AND INSTITUTIONAL
MARKETS. AND IT MANY HAVE LOST
HUGE NUMBERS OF CROPS BECAUSE
OF FAILED TO SUPPLY CHAINS. AND
SO FARM AND AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS AND ARE ESSENTIAL FOOD
SUPPLY CHAIN WORKERS MANY OF
THEM LIVE IN OVERCROWDED
HOUSING AS WE ALL KNOW. AND
THEY'VE BEEN ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO COVER NINETEEN AS
AS AS THE DATA. SUGGESTS IN.
AND STATES AND SO NOW THAT WE
ARE FINALLY BEGINNING TO EMERGE
FROM THIS. GLOBAL PANDEMIC IN
THIS CRISIS. WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR FOOD SYSTEM WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT IT STAYS HEALTHY.
THE NEXT CRISIS. AND SO WE NEED
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE AND THE
OPERATIONS THAT KEEP US FED. I
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
NO CALIFORNIAN GOES HUNGRY
BECAUSE IT'S UNACCEPTABLE- AND
SO THIS PROPOSED BILL THIS BOND
EFFORT WILL IMPROVE OUR FOOD
SYSTEM IN FOUR KEY WAYS FIRST
IT. PROPOSES TO INVEST IN FOOD
PROCESSING DISTRIBUTION AND
MARKET INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
INCREASE CAPACITY FOR EMERGENCY
FOOD- SO DISTRIBUTION ACROSS
OUR STATE. SECOND PROPOSES TO
PROTECT FARM AND FOOD SYSTEM
WORKERS BY MAKING INVESTMENTS
IN WORKFORCE HOUSING. BY
PROCURING WORKPLACE PP AND
INVESTING AND PUBLIC HEALTH
INITIATIVES FOR FARMING
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. THIRD IT
WOULD COMBAT HUNGER- AND EXPAND
HEALTHY FOOD ACCESS FOR OUR
SCHOOL STUDENTS MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES- AND FOR OUR SENIORS
IN THE STATE. AND FOR THIS
BOND- IT IT SEEKS TO PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE BY
INCREASING INVESTMENTS IN
EXISTING OVERPRESCRIBE CDFA
PROGRAMS- THAT. YOU'LL
CERTAINLY HAVE HAVE- I SHOWN TO
HAVE A- A BENEFIT FOR MANY
GROWERS IN THE STATE. A LOT OF
WORK HAS BEEN INVEST IN THIS
LEGISLATION- TO DATE THERE OF
WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SUPPORTING THIS
EFFORTS A SYMBOL OF THE
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN PROCESS WE
HAVE LED TO GET THIS POLICY TO
WHERE IT CURRENTLY IS. AND SO
WITH US THEY TESTIFY SAYS ARE
LARA THE MONTEREY BAY LABOR
AREA COUNCIL. KIRK WILBUR WE
CAN ASSOCIATION AND FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS JEAN
MERRILL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE.
NETWORK THANK YOU MISTER RUSSIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
BELIEVE- OPERATOR SHOULD HAVE
A- FEW. READY TO TESTIFY WELL
WE GET THEM IN THE QUEUE-
WILBUR I BELIEVE THIS WITH
CALLUM INITIATED GOING TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON SUPPORTING-
OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD GIVE IT
SAYS ARE LARA DIRECTOR MONTEREY
BAY AREA LABOR COUNCIL AND-
JEAN MERYL WITH CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURAL
NETWORK IN THE QUEUE AND WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND START WITH MR
WILBUR. OF WHY THE OPERATOR
DOES THAT. THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS KIRK WILBUR VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION FARMERS AND
RANCHERS IN CALIFORNIA REALLY
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. BY CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES LIKE WE EXPERIENCED
LAST YEAR RECURRING DROUGHTS
LIKE THE ONE WE ARE PRESENTLY
FACING AND INCREASING
TEMPERATURES THREATEN THE
LIVELIHOODS. OF R. RANCHO
MEMBERS WHO STEWARD NEARLY
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ACRES OF
CALIFORNIA'S RANGELAND. THESE
KIND OF CRISES ALSO THREATEN
THE AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTIVITY
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THE FOOD
SECURITY OF OUR CITIZENS.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY FIVE
RECOGNIZES THE GREATER
RESOURCES IN THE FORM OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ARE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT RANCHERS AND FARMERS.
IN ADAPTING TO GREATER WEATHER
EXTREMES IN WAYS THAT MAINTAIN
THE VIABILITY OF THE RANCHING
AND FARMING OPERATIONS. TO THAT
END ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY
FIVE INCLUDES OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN AGRICULTURAL
INVESTMENTS FROM PRESCRIBED
GRAZING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
INVESTMENTS IN CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE COMPOSTING
FACILITIES GROUNDWATER
PROTECTION. ESTABLISHING OUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS AS EVACUATION
CENTRE FOR LIVESTOCK DURING
EMERGENCIES AND MORE. AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE TAKES A MUCH NEEDED
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO LONG
TERM ECONOMIC VIABILITY AND
RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL AND FOOD SYSTEMS.
IMPORTANTLY MANY OF THESE VERY
SAME INVESTMENTS AS WELL AS
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS IN
CONSERVATION EASEMENT FUNDING
WILL PROMOTE CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND HELP US
MEET OUR AMBITIOUS THIRTY BY
THIRTY CONSERVATION GOALS. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MANY OTHERS
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY FIVE
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE ARE
EITHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
WILBUR. OPERATOR IF YOU CAN
GIVE IT MR LAUDA. YOU HAVE THEM
ON THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU TELL ME YES. H. YEAH GOOD
AFTERNOON- SURE REQUEST AND
MEMBERS MANY MISSED SUCH A LOT
I CAN BE EFFECTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE BATTERY BE CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL AFL-CIO AND WE ARE
PLEASED TODAY TO SUPPORT AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE WHICH TAKES A
COMPREHENSIVE INVESTMENT
APPROACH TO BE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IN CLIMATE RESILIENCE
OF OUR FOOD. AB FARM SYSTEM WE
ARE JOINED IN OUR SUPPORT BY
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY FARMS AND
FOOD BUSINESSES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FARMER FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AMERICAN
GROUP ORGANIZATIONS AND MUCH
MUCH MORE. DURING THIS AT THE
MARKET EMPIRES FARMWORKERS
WEBSTER HOW BY WORKING IN THE
FIELDS TO KEEP A SCRIPT. APPLE
IN MARCH- IN MY JOURNEY
FARMWORKERS ARE THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO CATCH THE COULD
HOPE IT- THE VIRUS COMPARED TO
OTHER. AB ONE FIVE WOULD
PROVIDE CRITICAL INVESTMENT IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
FARMWORKERS FAMILIES. STARTING
FOR THE STAR PRIDE PP FOR
WORKERS INVESTMENT FAR. HOW
ABSENT INDOOR AIR QUALITY AND
BETTER CONNECT FARMWORKERS
HOUSING WITH SERVICES AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE ALSO PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENT REGIONAL
FOOD. PROCESSING STORAGE AND
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS TYPICALLY
LOCAL CROPS FROM FARM TO TABLE
BE THE BEST MEN'S WILL MAKE OUR
FUTURE BETTER TO WITHSTAND.
DISRUPTIONS IN NINETEEN ACCESS
TO HELP YOU COULD FOR
CALIFORNIA I HEARD I URGE YEP
SPOKE FOR WORKING FAMILIES OF
ALL. OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LAW- OPERATOR
IF WE CAN GET MISS MERYL.
ONLINE. CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY
NAME'S JEANNIE AROUND THE
POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE TO MEGA
CULTURE NETWORK- I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THEY MAY HAVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
PROP- OPERATOR TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE VICTORIA DO.
OFFER IN COMPTON. SLATE BAY AND
BATH LOVE IT. ET FOR EARTH YOU
HAVE THEM IN THE QUEUE AND CAN
YOU GET THEM ON PLEASE. TRY
AGAIN FROM COMPASSIONATE THEY-
GO AHEAD WITH YOUR. OKAY HI
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME-
ALTHOUGH WE LIKE MANY ASPECTS
OF AB ONE TWENTY FIVE WE FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT SECTION
EIGHT OF SEVENTY ONE SHOULD NOT
BE GIVING AWAY A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS TO LIVESTOCK
AND DAIRY FARMERS TO SUBSIDIZE
QUESTIONABLE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION PRACTICES AND SIX
POINT MEASURE AT ALL OF THAT
THE INDUSTRY CREATED. WE MUST
THAT HOLD POLLUTERS ACCOUNTABLE
AND DIRECTOR TIME AND LIMITED
PUBLIC RESOURCES TOWARD RAPIDLY
TRANSITIONING TO ACTUALLY LOW
CARBON AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM. THE
SECTION I MENTIONED PROPOSES TO
REDUCE METHANE AND CO TWO
EMISSIONS THEIR PASTURE BASED
GRAZING GRADING AND OTHER HOT
TREND THAT IS THE TARGET OF
POPULAR TED TALK LEAVING REVIEW
RESEARCH HAS BEEN MORE
SOBERING. NO ROGUE RESOURCES
INSTITUTE IN THE US AND THE
FOOD CLIMATE RESEARCH NETWORK
IN THE UK. HAVE COME TO SIMILAR
CONCLUSIONS. THAT THE- COULD AS
A AGRICULTURE APPROVED HEALTH
YOUR- VALUABLE EMPIRE BACK. BUT
ARE UNLIKELY TO ACHIEVE BY
SCALE EMISSIONS REDUCTION. AND
QUOTE. ONE THAT THE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF QUEUES CLUSTER
THROUGH GRADE WHAT EVENTUALLY
BACK POINT AND ALL THE WHILE
THE LAST RECORD FILLED. CAN
COOK IS NOT THE METHANE. HERE
INTERROGATION INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE. IN A TO HAVE ANY
HOPE DEALING WITH CLIMATE. WE
HAVE TO SHOW OUR STUFF EITHER
WAY LIVESTOCK WELCOME FORMER
RENDITION. WE CAN TAKE IT FOR A
FROM THE K. JUST ON AN
AGRICULTURAL REVOLUTION BY
BREAKING AWAY FROM THE EUROPEAN
UNION I'M FIFTIES. INSTEAD THEY
STARTED PAYING FARMERS FOR LONG
TERM CARBON SEQUESTRATION THANK
YOU ARE THEIR LAND FOR TREE
PLANTATION RESTORING PEATLANDS.
CAN'T STOP THAT SO THAT THEY
BECOME CARBON SINKS OR OTHER
PUBLIC GOODS. WE CAN START
DOING THAT HERE TOO I WOULD CAN
THEN VERIFY THEIR INCOME STREAM
MAKING. THEM MORE ECONOMICALLY
RESILIENT. WE RESERVE OPPOSED A
LOT THE OF CRG INTO DATA YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MISS TO
THE IS IT IS IT MISTER MISS LAW-
FROM EAT FOR THE EARTH OPERATOR
DO WE OFFER ONLY. YES MY NAME
IS REVEREND BETH LOVE AND I'M
HERE TO TESTIFY AGAINST CERTAIN
ELEMENTS OF AB ONE TWENTY FIVE
SPECIFICALLY CHAPTER TWO EIGHT
OH SEVEN TWO ONE THE VICTORIAN
MANSION SECTION EIGHT THREE
EIGHT AND ALSO EIGHT EIGHT. AND
ALL OTHER PORTIONS OF THE BILL
THAT PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
LIVESTOCK DAIRY OR FISH
OPERATIONS OR THAT INCLUDES
MEAT OR DAIRY AND FEEDING
PROGRAMS ANIMAL AGRICULTURE IS
A LEADING CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS DEFORESTATION
SPECIES EXTINCTION OCEAN DEAD
ZONES AND MULTIPLE ADDITIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISES. DOZENS OF
RECENT PEER REVIEWED STUDIES
CONCLUDE THAT SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN ANIMAL FOOD
PRODUCTION AND DIETARY SHIFTS
TOWARD MORE PLANTS ARE CRUCIAL
ELEMENTSIN ANY EFFECTIVE PLAN
FOR ADDRESSING THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. CONSUMPTION OF MEAT
DAIRY FISH AND EGGS IS BLANKS
TO KILLER DISEASES SUCH AS
HEART DISEASE DIABETES ASTHMA
STROKE ALZHEIMER'S AND CANCER
CONDITIONS THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT AND
KILL PEOPLE OF COLOR AND OTHER
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS
ADDITIONALLY MANY OF THESE
DISEASE AN INCREASED RISK FOR
SEVERE AND FATAL COVERT
NINETEEN FACTIONS. FURTHER
VIRAL PANDEMICS HAVE ARISEN
FROM LIVESTOCK OPERATIONS IN
THE PAST AND LIKELY WILL AGAIN
AN EDITORIAL IN THE JOURNAL
BIOSCIENCE SIGNED BY OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND SCIENTISTS.
CONCLUDES THAT EATING MOSTLY
PLANT FOODS WHILE REDUCING THE
GLOBAL CONSUMPTION OF ANIMAL
PRODUCTS CAN IMPROVE HUMAN
HEALTH AND SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SINCE
THE PURPOSE OF AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE IS TO ENSURE A SECURE
RESILIENT SUSTAINABLE AND
EQUITABLE FOOD AND FARMING
SYSTEM IT IS ANTITHETICAL TO
THE BILL'S PURPOSES TO INCLUDE
SUPPORT FOR ANIMAL AGRICULTURE.
AND INDUSTRY THAT BEAR
SIGNIFICANT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
CLIMATE CHAOS FOOD INSECURITY
PANDEMIC. RISK AND
DISPROPORTIONATE POOR HOW ABOUT
COMES FOR MEMBERS MARGIN
COMMUNITIES I RISK. URGE AB ONE
TWENTY FIVE BE AMENDED TO
REMOVE HANDOUTS TO ANIMAL
AGRICULTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU REVENUE LOVE- AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT- DO
WE HAVE ANY ONLINE MR OPERATOR.
I HAVE SEVERAL IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO OF
VOICE AN OPINION ON THIS PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE SIXTY
FIVE. GO AHEAD PLEASE. WE'LL GO
TO LINE. THIRTY THREE. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL DIMOCK I AM THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF- TO CHANGE
A PROGRAM OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE I'M HERE AT ONE OF
THAT SIXTEEN CO SPONSORS OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWO FIVE.
FOUR CO SPONSORED BECAUSE ONE
TWO FIVE MEETS THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES AND
ESSENTIALLY THAT WILL BE
FRAUGHT WITH CHALLENGES I'M
GOING TO LIST THE NAMES OF
TWELVE OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WILL
ALSO STAND BEHIND AB ONE TO
FIVE AND UP GIVEN ME PERMISSION
TO SHARE THEIR SUPPORT DURING
THIS HEARING. THEY ARE CENTER
VEHICLE LITERACY HUMILITY
ENVIRONMENTAL COUNCIL ALLIANCE
OF NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENTS FAMILIES
ADVOCATING FOR CHEMICAL AND
TOXIN SAFETY ALSO KNOWN AS
FACTS HEALTH CARE WITHOUT HARM
ONE FAIR WAGE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE SOCIAL JUSTICE
LEARNING INSTITUTE SEAN RIGHTS
MOVEMENT OF ORANGE COUNTY. THE
EDIBLE SCHOOLYARD CENTER PER
URBAN EDUCATION ABOUT
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE ALSO
KNOWN AS QUAKER AND. SIERRA
HARVEST THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE SIXTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE INCIDENT
WERE NOT YET WHAT THE CLIMATE
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY TWO.
SHARE MEMBERS KATHY MOSCOW THAT
WE HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AS WELL AS MEALS ON
WHEELS CALIFORNIA BOTH IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWO FIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS NOT A
LUXURY FROM THE POLICY NOW
REACH SPECIALIST BACK
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS AND I'M HERE AS ONE OF
THE SIXTEEN CO SPONSORS- IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWENTY FIVE
I'M ALSO GOING TO LIST THE
NAMES OF THIRTEEN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ALSO TEN
BEHIND THE BILL AND HAVE GIVEN
ME PERMISSION TO SHARE THEIR
SUPPORT DURING THIS HEARING-
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS ARE ACT CARE
ACT ACTION FOR A HEALTHY
PLANET. ZERO TWO PRINT GMO
CREEK CALIFORNIA ASIAN BUSINESS
INSTITUTE AND RESEARCH CENTRE
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIC.
ENTERPRISES OF LOS ANGELES.
COSIGNER FARMERS. TANK SHOT THE
FARMERS MARKET A BETTER COURSE
FOR ALAMEIN THE FARMERS MARKET.
RUSTIC CANYON FAMILY REPUBLIC
SERVICES. REPURPOSE THANK AND
THE SAN BURDEN TO YOU SAN
BERNARDINO VALLEY CONCERT
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MR OFFERING- HOW MANY IN
FORTY GO AHEAD. PARDON ME WE
HAVE- RIGHT NOW THIRTEEN LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU- IF YOU'RE IN
Q. IF YOU COULD JUST PLEASE
GIVE IT TO YOU- NAME AN
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE. NINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MAIN ABRUPT- IN YOUR
ADVOCATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL WE
ARE ALSO ONE OF THE SIXTEEN CO
SPONSORS OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY FIVE. AND WITH THIS
BILL- WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA REALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SHAPE OUR
OPERATING FARMING THANK THEM TO
MEET. YES FOR PLEASE. NINE
SIXTY THREE. AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS CHENEY CALLING BEHALF
OF ADVISEMENT AND FIND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY ONE. SHE MADE SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS ANDREA TERRY
REPRESENTING NO KID HUNGRY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
THIRTY ONE. STATE RUN CENTER
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS WE ARE CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY TWO. HI THIS IS THE BEST
SMOKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
AND FARMING NETWORK AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BELL ALONG
WITH NINETEEN OF OUR MEMBERS
WHO HAVE GIVEN ME PERMISSION TO
LET THEM IN SUPPORT TODAY- BUT
INCLUDED THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK CALIFORNIA
HER HEALTH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
CALIFORNIA FARM LINK CALIFORNIA
WORLD LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE. IT'S COMMUNITY PROJECT
ECOLOGY CENTER ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP. FIBER SHED
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH. LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA MARIN FOOD POLICY
COUNCIL NURSE CALIFORNIA.
SACRAMENTO FOOD POLICY COUNCIL.
SECOND HARVEST OF SILICON
VALLEY QUOTED CALIFORNIA THE
PRACTICE PROJECT AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN CAPE
COUNCIL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY ONE. I MEAN MARK
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR
FOOD SAFETY AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY SIX. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
UNITED DAIRIES REPRESENTING THE
DAIRY FARMERS CALIFORNIA WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY NINE. LINE FORTY
NINE IF YOU NEED TO RE QUEUE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN WIDE.
SEVENTY THREE. I BELIEVE THE
SONS OF DISCONNECTED LINE SIXTY
NINE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON QUESTION NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACES FORTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
NINE. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
LOW. IF YOU CAN HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE PLEASE. OKAY
MY NAME IS MARGARET NOT THEN I
MADE- RESIDENT CALIFORNIA I
HAVE NO ORGANIZATIONS BUT I AM
IN OPPOSITION PARTICULARLY TO
THE- PROVISIONS THAT PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR LIVESTOCK OPERATE
YOU. NEXT PLEASE OPERATOR WHAT
LINE. SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS ARE
BACK IN MARKETS THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE GIVEN THE
COMMISSION TELEPHONY SUPPORT
RATHER THAN CALL AND SEPARATELY
THE TO ORGANIZATIONS ARE THAT
IMPORTANT ON TOP OF THE BELL
THE AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE OF
MARIN AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM CURRENT CYCLE INSTITUTE
CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK CENTRAL BY
NACIONAL PARA EL DIFFICULT REAL
INDIE NOT LOCKING YEAH
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS INTERTRIBAL
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL MONTEREY
BAY CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK. RICHARD CHANGE AND
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURAL
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINE IN Q.
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
IN THE CHAMBER AND OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT TOWARDS SEEN NON-
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS FOR
MEMBER COMMENTS. MISTER FLORA
FOLLOWED BY MISTER GRAY AND
THEN MISTER SAWYER. THANK YOU
TERRY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS OUT FORWARD. HIS ANY
OPPOSITION STILL ON THE PHONE
LINE. MR OPERATOR. YES YEAH I'M
STILL ON THE CURRICULA I'M-
OKAY I AM TOO- WITHIN THAT. YES
I JUST HAVE A FEW FEW QUESTIONS
FOR WHOEVER ACTUALLY WANTS TO
ANSWER THEM- BECAUSE I DO FIND
YOUR OPPOSITION FASCINATING-
IMAGINE A NUMBER OF TIMES LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND HOW. AND WHY
THIS IS IMPORTANT- I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THAT. I REPRESENT ONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES. THERE'S A LOT OF
TALK AT ARMS CAN BRING RIGHT
DOWN TO TACO TRUCKS. THANK YOU
CAN BUY A TACO FOR DOLLAR. YOU
CAN FEED YOUR FAMILY FOR TEN
DOLLARS WITH TEN TACOS. NOT A
LOT OF MY COMMUNITY IS EATEN
TOFU TACOS FROM TACO TRUCKS
OKAY THEY LIKE THEIR MEAT. SO
GETTING PASSES PREMISE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IN OUR
ENTIRE. STATE INTO A PANIC
PLANT BASED PROTEIN DIET. IS
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED. SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID I AM CURIOUS.
WHY DOES THE OPPOSITION
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE. INDUSTRIES
EFFORT TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT YOU SAY THAT YOU
CARE ABOUT. FILLED WITH FEEL
FREE TO ANSWER. I WOULD LOVE TO
TAKE THAT- AND I'LL I WANT TO
START BY SAYING THE REASON THAT
I SAY THAT- PEOPLE COLOR
MARGINALIZED AT THE
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
ANIMAL AGRICULTURE IS TWO FOLD
ONE IS THAT I DON'T- I DON'T
KNOW I WANT TO I WANT TO ANSWER
ON WHY CLOSE THE FUND OKAY. FOR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. I
OKAY THANK YOU I DO NOT OPPOSE
FUNDING TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BUT I- SEE THAT
THERE IS AN ANIMAL AGRICULTURE
IS AN INDUSTRY THAT ALREADY HAS
LARGE SUBSIDIES. AND THOSE
SUBSIDIES ARTIFICIALLY LOWER
THE PRICE SO THAT THOSE TACOS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CAN BE AS
CHEAP AS THEY ARE IF THE
SUBSIDIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
EXISTING WERE TAKEN AWAY. THEN
PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE TO AFFORD
THE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES MORE
EASILY I LOVED IT AN EARLIER
BILL IS SUPPORTING FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES. THE PRICE IS NOT
PART OF THE LOOKED TOWARD AND
THE OTHER PART OF IT. GLAZER
pEXPENSIVE THAN HAMBURG. SO
RIGHT I KNOW BECAUSE SUBSIDIES
ARE NOT THAT'S THE PROBLEM
THAT'S EXACTLY THAT'S WHY I'M
SAYING THAT IF YOU IF YOU
ACTUALLY HAD TO BUY THAT
HAMBURGER FOR WHAT IT COST TO
ASSIST US AS A SOCIETY TO CLEAN
UP THE MESS FROM AND TO DEAL
WITH THE CLIMATE ISSUES TO DEAL
WITH THE HEALTH ISSUES IT WILL
COST FOURTEEN DOLLARS PER FROM
NEED AN ONYX CAN I. ASK YOU
WOULD YOU PREFER MORE PEOPLE DE
SALADS REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT IS. A LARGER
THREAT TO US- YES I WORK EVERY
DAY. TO TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS BECAUSE IT IS THAT YOU
JUST WHAT THE HUGE AMOUNT HI.
OKAY THIS AND ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS WHAT. BECAUSE YOUR
OPPOSITION THEM CONTRA LAST
AFTER OUR MY IF YOU'RE GONNA
ASK FOR MY OPINION RESPECTFULLY
PLEASE LET ME FINISH BECAUSE I
HAVE SOME INSULIN ALTERATION TO
BRING HERE. AND STAY ON TOPIC
MELANIE FETISH IT'S- K. PLEASE
FINISH. MY SIMPLE QUESTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SHARE RIGHT
YOU CAN TYPE SO YES THERE. ARE
I CLICK MY- I MY JOB AS A
MINISTER MY PAID JOB. BECAUSE
OF HOW MUCH THEY CARE ABOUT THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AND I WANT YOUR
CHILDREN AND MINE TOP- WHERE WE
CAN LIVE. JUDY AND SO YES I
CARE ABOUT REDUCING EMISSIONS.
BUT THE WAY TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
IS NOT TO SUBSIDIZE AN INDUSTRY
THAT IS CREATING A MISSION IT
IS TO INVITE THAT THAT INDUSTRY
TO TRANSFORM AS VICTORIA WAS
MENTIONING IN THE UK THERE NOW
INSTEAD OF SUBSIDIZING THE
PRODUCTION OF ANIMAL PRODUCTS
OR OTHER FARM PRODUCTS THEY ARE
SUBSIDIZING. SEQUESTRATION OF
CARBON AND THIS BILL IS FLAWED
BECAUSE IT GIVES AN INDUSTRY
ANOTHER HAND OUT AN INDUSTRY
THAT DOESN'T NEED IT THAT IS
THAT IS THE BUT LEAVE IT THERE
ARE THERE ARE NINE PLANETARY
DOWNTOWN GREASE FIVE OF WHICH
WE HAVE ALREADY CROSSED INTO
UNSAFE OR POTENTIALLY UNSAFE
TERRITORY IN ANIMAL AGRICULTURE
IS THE LEAD AND FOUR OF THOSE
INCLUDING THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND WE CANNOT AFFORD TO KEEP
PRETENDING THAT THIS ACT AND
THAT THIS INDUSTRY- CAN
CONTINUE AT THE RATE THAT IT IS
WE NEED TO CHANGE YOUR DIET THE
SCIENCE IS VERY CLEAR WE NEED
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF ANIMALS
THAT WE RAISE FOR FOOD I DON'T
NEED TO CHANGE YOUR DIET. WILL
NOT MESS WITH IT WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO KEEP FROM. GOING INTO A
RUNAWAY GLOBAL. AND I THINK
THAT. I APPRECIATE THAT OKAY
THAT I AND I CAN MORNING AND I
ASSURE YOUR ABOUT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR KIDS CHECK
OUT I ALSO WANT TO BE ABLE TO.
OKAY AND I DON'T CARE THAT WE
HAVE IN INDIA THIS TO THE TABLE.
TO REDUCE THEIR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT PRODUCE MEAT AND
MILK THAT ALLOW OUR KIDS TO
SURVIVE. OKAY SO CAN.
CONTRACTORS MATT MA'AM YOUR- A
MEMBER YOUR YOUR TIME IS UP
MISTER FLORNOY CONCLUDE YOUR
REMARKS PLEASE I'LL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS- THANK YOU. MISTER
GRAY. YOUR YOUR REMARKS ARE
FALSE DICHOTOMY BETWEEN EATING
A SALAD ADAM MA'AM IT'S NOT
YOUR TOTAL THIS WEEK YOU HAVE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY. THE R.
OPERATOR IF THAT WOULD MAKE IT
A LOT. GLORIA TO GET IN. THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD MUTE THE
LINE INTEL- THEY ARE ADDRESSED
BY A MEMBER THROUGH THE CHAIR
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR. I THANK YOU JERRY
THIS FOR BRING IN THIS- BEFORE
US TODAY- ALL ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
REPPAN SHARED WITH US- THE
HYPOCRISY IN THIS STATE. THAT
MANY OF US WHO REPRESENT RURAL
AND AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES
DEAL WITH ALMOST DAILY IF NOT
HOURLY HERE AT THE STATE
CAPITOL. IF YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
WE SHOULDN'T SUBSIDIZE
INDUSTRIES BUT THEN WE END UP
SUBSIDIZING SPORTS CARS. FOR
PEOPLE IN THE BAY AREA HOW WAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE. MEETING OUR-
I AM IT TO GOALS WE'RE GONNA.
GIVE THAT PERSON THAT NEEDED.
YOU KNOW SIX OR SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR SUBSIDY ON A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS SPORTS CAR.
BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE. WHEN NOW VICE
PRESIDENT KAMILLA HARRIS CAME.
THROUGH MY DISTRICT CAMPAIGNING
FOR A DIFFERENT JOB WHEN SHE
WAS RUNNING FOR STATEWIDE
OFFICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WINTERSON CONVERSATION. WHERE
WE SAT WITH A BUNCH OF. ADD
BUSINESS PEOPLE FOR MY DISTRICT
AND WENT AROUND THE ROOM AND
TALK TO EVERYBODY AND- EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN THE ROOM THE
NEW APPRECIATE THIS MISTER
CHAIRMAN INTRODUCED THEMSELVES
AS A SMALL FAMILY FORMER. I
LOOKED AROUND THE ROOM AND I
THOUGHT. I DON'T KNOW SOMEONE
SMOKES ACCOUNT BIG FAMILY FROM
WHICH I KNOW HOW I'VE BEEN TO
THE FARMS. I SAID TO MADAM VICE
PRESIDENT. ISN'T IT INTERESTING
THAT WHEN YOU COME TO OUR PART
OF THE WORLD. WE HAVE TO
INTRODUCE OURSELVES AS SMALL.
FAMILY FARMERS. FOR US NOT TO
BE PAINTED. WITH THE BRUSH OF
CORPORATE ADD EVIL EVIL FARMERS.
I THINK IS WHEN I GO TO IT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE PART OF THE WORLD
UP IN THE BAY AREA. I NEVER
HAVE ANYBODY AT GOOGLE OR
FACEBOOK INTRODUCED THEMSELVES
AS A SMALL FAMILY TECH COMPANY.
FOR SOME REASON THEY DON'T HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
SUCCESSFUL BIG AND I'LL GO EVEN
FURTHER WE DON'T INTRODUCE
BILLS LIKE THE ONE MR GARCIA
HAD HERE A FEW MINUTES AGO.
IMAGINE A BILL THAT SAID IF YOU
DON'T. FOLLOW OUR LABOR
STANDARDS IN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO
IMPORT COMPUTER CHIPS. HOW WE
DOING THAT ANYTIME SOON. ALL
PROBABLY NOT. AND THAT BRINGS
ME TO YOUR BILL. WHICH AGAIN I
WANT TO START BY SAYING THANK
YOU I KNOW. YOUR HEART AND YOUR
HEAD OR IN THE RIGHT PLACE WITH
THE SELF. BUT WE LIVE IN A
STATE. WHERE WE SUFFER FROM
DROUGHTS AND FLOODS. IN THE
SAME YEAR. WHATEVER YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE HOW DO
YOU SUFFER FROM A DROUGHT IN
THE FLOOD. IN THE SAME YEAR.
WHY AM AN IDEA. THIS BECAUSE
WE'VE BUILT. SO LITTLE WATER
STORAGE IN THE LAST FOUR
DECADES A 1% INCREASE FOLKS BY
THE STATE IN OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE LAST
FORTY YEARS AT A TIME WHERE WE
MORE THAN DOUBLED. CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION. AND IT'S LIKE
ADDITION BY SUBTRACTION WITH
THE FOLKS HERE AT THE STATE
CAPITOL WHERE WE'RE GONNA TAKE
YOUR WATER YOU CAN'T PUMP IT
OUT OF THE GROUND YOU CAN'T
HAVE FROM THE RIVERS OVER NOT
GOING TO BUILD A DAM. BUT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO EXPECT THE
SHELVES TO MIRACULOUSLY PRODUCE
FOOD AT WHOLE FOODS. AND
OBNOXIOUS PRICES BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BAN OUT OF STATE STUFF
TO. IT'S GET OLD AND- YOU KNOW
WHEN THE VOTERS PASSED. CHANGES
TO TERM LIMIT LAWS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY ALLOWED
SUPPOSED TO STICK AROUND A
LITTLE LONGER IN THE SAME
HOUSE. HE GAVE THIS BODY SOME
CONTINUITY SOME LONGEVITY RIGHT
SOME INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY AND
AS I SEE HERE THIS MORNING I
THINK BACK TO WHEN I WAS FAIRLY
NEW AROUND HERE. IT WAS MY
SECOND TERM WE DID THE WATER
BOND I DON'T THINK YOU WERE
HERE YET MISTER CHAIRMAN-
ALTHOUGH WE WISH WE'D HAD YOU
HERE- AT THAT TIME. BUT WE
NEGOTIATED AN AGREEMENT WITH
THAT THEN THE A GENTLEMAN WHO
WAS CHAIR OF THE WATER
COMMITTEE. HAPPENS TO BE
SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY NOW. AND
WE MADE AN AGREEMENT WITH THE-
AUTHOR. WITH THE GOVERNOR WITH
THE SENATE THAT WE'RE GONNA
SPEND THREE BILLION DOLLARS A
WATER STORAGE. NAMELY TO GET
TWO MAJOR STORAGE PROJECTS
SITES RESERVOIR ABOVE
SACRAMENTO AND TEMPERANCE FLAT.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
NEITHER OF WHICH- WELL NEITHER
OF THOSE PROMISES HAVE BEEN
FULFILLED RIGHT AND IN FACT. A
CERTAIN INJURY WHY I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS IF YOU CAN GET TO
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL PLACE
Y. GOT AWFUL LOT TO SAY MISTER
GERMINOMA I SEE. NO MY FRIEND
THE REST. THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE
FAILED TO. ACTUALLY INVEST IN
AGRICULTURE THE WAY WE SHOULD
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY BROUGHT THIS.
PROPOSAL FORWARD I IN EFFORT TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
ALTHOUGH ALL SAY THERE'S NOT
ANY WATER STORAGE IN THIS WHICH
I THINK'S A MAJOR SHORTCOMING.
AND MOREOVER THERE'S NOT.
SPECIFICITY AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS. GETTING INTO SPECIFIC
PROJECTS THE REASON I BRING
THAT UP IS BECAUSE WILL WHEN
THIS BODY ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
VOTED FOR WATER BOND FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THOSE
PROMISES WERE LATER BROKEN.
LACK OF SPECIFICITY LEADS
OPPORTUNITY FOR BROKEN PROMISES
RIGHT AND SO I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD ASK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
IS IF YOU WOULD BE OPEN I'M NOT
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY IS IT'S A TWO THIRDS VOTE
MY ONE. I WANT TO COME ON BOARD
WITH THIS BOND WHEN I KNOW IT'S
IN THE QUEUE IN THE- DECISION
THAT WE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS THAT I THINK. ARE
IMPORTANT FOR MY DISTRICT AND
OTHERS- BUT I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THE SPECIFICITY AND
HOW WE- DEAL WITH WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE AGAIN TO
SUFFER FROM FLOODS AND DROUGHTS
IN THE SAME YEAR AND I KNOW I'M
PREACHING TO THE CHOIR HERE-
BUT I WANT TO RAISE THESE
ISSUES PUBLICLY. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FFORTS TO
ADDRESS THESE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH YOU.
GOING FORWARD. AT THE YPJ THE
COMMENTS AND YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
OPEN TO- ENGAGING. OVER THE
ISSUE I MEAN IT'S- CERTAINLY-
AS- A SIGNIFICANT ONE. SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER GRAY MR
SHROYER I PROBABLY HAVE A WHOLE
LOT LESS TO SEE THE STATUS OF
MY DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE OF.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FORTH THE SAME BASIS-
BOND MEASURE OF THE MEMBER
SOUTH LA YOU KNOW MANY TIMES
PEOPLE QUESTION. ME EVEN ON
THIS COMMITTEE- BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THIS- IT'S MEASURES
LIKE THIS THAT CAN TRULY MAKE
AN IMPACT IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE. WHO LACK ACCESS TO FRESH.
AND HEALTHY FOOD REALLY BY
INVESTING ABOUT SEVENTY FIFTY
MILLION TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTHY FOOD- WE ARE FIRM IN
OUR COMMITMENT TO COMBAT HUNGER
FOR AN ESTIMATED SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
EXPERIENCING FOOD INSECURITY SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DILIGENCE
WITH THIS MEASURE. AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT. THANK YOU MISTER SIR ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE FIRST. THANK YOU
A SUMMARY OF SPRING AFFORD YOU
KNOW WASN'T A COMMON CAUSE MR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY BROUGHT UP
SOME GOOD POINTS AND I JUST
WANT TO HOPE THAT YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIM I
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT MAKING SURE
WE HAD OUR WATER PIECE IN THERE
AND- THIS WHAT IS WE HAVE THESE
COMPANIES IS TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION SO I APPRECIATE
THAT NIGHT I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY WITH A POPPING UP I
REALLY HOPE THAT YOU WILL
CONSIDER WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY. ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS MEMBERS
GOING ONCE GOING TWICE BACK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR CLOTHES.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT UP
BUDGET THE COMMENTS AND- THE
DIALOGUE AND RESPECT THAT'S
WHEN I'LL. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL. ON AB ONE TWENTY FIVE
RIVAS MOTION AS DO PASSED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS RIVERSIDE
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA LARA I
AGREE. FOR NOT VOTING- ONE
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER AYE LEVINE LEVINE I'D BE
ABLE TO WALK FEEL GOOD WHILE I
WOULD. WOOD I STILL HAS A
TENDENCY. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY. I THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY AND SO IF WE CAN-
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ON ITEMS THAT NEED A
VOTE ON MEASURE I. ONE HANDLE
THAT IF. YEAH OKAY THAT WORKS.
ON THE ASSEMBLY RULES. GREAT.
ON THAT GREAT I WOULD WHAT I
PASS ON TO ON ITEM ONE AB ONE
OH OH NINE BLOOM THE MOTION WAS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I AGREE.
WOOD WOULD I AGREE NOT VOTING.
YEAH I AGREE I THANK YOU. HOW
DOES TEN VOTES. ON AB EIGHT
SIXTY SIX DOLLY- MOTION DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS GRAY.
GRAY I WOULD. WOOD I. ELEVEN
VOTES. ON A. B. ELEVEN OH
THREE. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE GREAT. RAY I WOULD.
WOULD I THE BILL HAS ELEVEN
VOTES. ON AB SEVEN TEN GARCIA-
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS GRAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRANK ON AB SEVEN TEN
GARCIA NOW. THANK YOU ON AB
THREE FIFTY VEHICLE TO WALK
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
GRAY. GRAY I. AND THAT'S ALL.
SORRY SORRY SORRY MISTER CHAIR
ON THEY CAN THANK YOU ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SORRY ABOUT
THAT HOLD ON ONE SECOND. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. I THOUGHT I
CALLED ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY WAS
AYE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY AND WE STAND
ADJOURNED.